figaro la ville est un petit peu plus de
huit heures et demie 8h33 pour être
précis nous sommes en direct sur
lefigaro.fr et sur notre page youtube
figaro live à l'occasion de l'audition
par les députés français de frances
haugen sept lanceurs d'alertés
américaine qui défie facebook
aujourd'hui alors elle doit être
entendue par les députés de la
commission des affaires économiques et
des lois de l'assemblée nationale d'ici
une petite demi-heure on va dire que
l'audition est prévu à 9 heures ce sera
évidemment à suivre en direct sur figaro
live alors restez avec rester avec nous
mais juste avant que cela ne démarre
nous allons pouvoir poser ensemble les
enjeux de cette audition et apprendre à
découvrir pour ceux qui ne la
connaissent pas qui est cette lanceuse
d'alert nous allons vous présenter qui
est france sas aux jeunes avec moi dans
le studio pour en parler océane herrero
une bonjour océane vous êtes journaliste
au service économie du figaro vous avez
écrit un papier notamment sur franz et
hogan et vous à nous éclairer donc sur
ce sujet d'actualité d'ailleurs si vous
avez des questions n'hésitez pas à nous
les poser dans lé chat je vous lis je
vous vois c'est pour ça que j'ai mon
ordinateur avec moi donc je suis le chat
sur lefigaro.fr et sur youtube n'hésitez
pas à poser vos commentaires et à à
poser vos questions je les relais ray en
direct alors première question toute
simple océane on va d'abord parlé de
cette personne qui est française morgane
qu'elle est calé son cv en quelque sorte
une française au ghana elle est née dans
l'iowa c'est un un état assez assez
agricoles des états unis elle a utilisé
dans le massachusetts l'informatique
avant d'entamer sa carrière dans l'info
dans l'informatique surtout la tech donc
en 2006 elle a son diplôme et elle
commence sa carrière chez google où elle
travaille sur le projet projet google+
qui est un réseau social qui était censé
concurrencer facebook entre autres un
peu son succès
elle reste donc plusieurs années chez
facebook et elle quitte le géant google
et google pardon il y reste donc
plusieurs années avant de partir et de
rejoindre y est donc un site consacré à
la recommandation d' adresses de
restaurants etc elle y passe deux ans si
je me trompe pas avant de partir chez
pink intéressant notre réseau social
puis finalement d'arriver chez facebook
en 2018 où elle va se diriger assez
rapidement à sa demande vers un
département particulier qui est le civic
integrity qui s'occupe de tout ce qui
est
contrôle des usages de la plateforme
dans le cas d'élection pour éviter les
manipulations donc voilà un intérêt
assez prononcé assez rapide pour ce qui
concerne les news voilà les faits que
nous faisons entre autres et la probité
des réseaux sociaux sur des questions un
peu sensibles comme les élections à
cette adresse aussi beaucoup à tout ce
qui est des algorithmes hic donc
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un algorithme
va pousser certains contenus plus que
d'autres c'est quelque chose qui va
l'intéresser assez rapidement reste
combien de temps chez facebook
concrètement deux en deux ans avant de
démissionner en mai 2021
avec sous le bras donc les facebook
files ces documents dont on parle
beaucoup ces dernières semaines qu'ils
sont des milliers de copies de documents
qu'elle a pu amasser chez durant son
temps passé chez facebook alors on va
revenir en détail donc sur ses fesses et
facebook files qui sont donc le
principal fait d'armes de frances hogan
mais avant cela on va on va parler un
petit peu de son actualité
car évidemment il s'est exprimé devant
le congrès américain puis ensuite le
parlement britannique et lundi soir elle
était devant le parlement européen
elle a de nouveau accusé son ancien
employeur donc facebook je cite de nuire
aux enfants d'attiser les difficiles les
divisions affaiblir démocratie et faire
passer le profit avant la sécurité des
utilisateurs
écoutez ce qu'elle a dit notamment au
parlement européen
faux
alors bonjour à pierre michel gérard du
cru qui nous saluent dans le tchat sur
youtube et à chantal antoine qui nous
fait pas de son commentaire bonjour les
lanceurs d'alertés sont très utiles
effectivement on va on va voir si elle
aura une utilité si son alerte
aura un impact on va dire sur les gens
de la tech mais d'abord océane
j'aimerais qu'on parle de cette tournée
européenne pourquoi française au ghana
et en europe
quel est son objectif à rencontrer tous
les députés on va dire des principaux
pays européens où ils allaient passer en
prime et donc non beaucoup de pays elle
était au parlement britannique elle
était à lisbonne au tec ce mythe elle
est en france aujourd'hui donc assemblée
sénat est en fait il ya beaucoup d'enjeu
en europe actuellement puisqu'elle la
discussion de deux règlements au niveau
européen qui sont le 18 heures au
service actes et le jitter market act le
premier a pour but de réguler les gars
femmes en demandant plus de transparence
et le dm aldi danemark et axel pour but
d'éviter qui est un des monopoles en
terme
sur les marchés publicitaires en fait
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient créés par
par ces plateformes là donc c'est des
textes assez important dans la
régulation des gars femme est française
ou guen espère peser en fait sur les
discussions qui vont être menées en
intervenant en amont devancé assez
devant le parlement européen et en
france il ya aussi la discussion de la
transposition d'une directive européenne
concernant la protection des lanceurs
d'alerté qui est entamée donc elle peut
aussi espérer peser sur ces discussions
là est ce qu'on sait si c'est elle qui
s'est invité qui a fait cette tournée ou
si c'est au contraire des députés des
eurodéputés qui sont partisans d'une
meilleure révélation qui l'ont invité
pour un peu
parlé dans leur sens en fait les
convaincre peut-être les autres députés
qui sont plutôt dans l'autre bord s'est
rapidement rendue disponible par par
l'entremise du coût de ces de ses
équipes puisqu'elle est assez soutenu
aller c'est une ong qui s'appelle le
minatd qui est
organisée plus ou moins directement sa
campagne entre guillemets européenne
donc c'est une ong qui et qui est
financé par pierre mignard qui est
l'ancien enfin le fondateur d' ib qui
est devenu assez critique des de la big
tech et qui aujourd'hui financent ce
type d'opération donc voilà c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est assez orchestrée
qui a été bien organisé par rapport à
ces équipes de manière à ce qu'elles
puissent
être présentes dans un maximum de
l'institution européenne possible au
cours des semaines qui sont passés alors
en préparant cette émission en lisant
plusieurs articles dont un portrait de
nos confrères du monde on apprend que
petite elle hésitait entre avocate
biologistes ou même femme politique en
fait comme métier alors là on se rend
compte avec cette tournée quel peut-être
qu'elle réalise un petit peu son son
rêve d'être femme politique à ce qu'elle
a des ambitions politiques derrière ça à
ce stade c'est difficile à dire
mais parce qu'elle reste très concentré
sur les enjeux qui concernent qui
concerne facebook mais ce qui est
certain c'est qu'elle a très bien
préparé sa sortie de facebook en étant
épaulé par un certain nombre
d'organisations donc c'est à l'écologie
cités auparavant mais aussi
whistleblower aide qui est une
organisation américaine américaine qui
vise à soutenir les lanceurs d'alerté
parce qu'elle veut aussi être protégés
par le statut de nos soeurs d'alert qui
accorde un certain nombre de garanties
pour des profils comme comme les siens
donc voilà pour le moment elle reste
très concentré sur les enjeux de
facebook mais à l'avenir il faudra
guetter on sait surveillé
si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes
toujours en direct sur lefigaro.fr et
sur notre page youtube figaro live à
propos enfin pour discuter dont deux de
france aso gagnent 7 lanceuse d'alert
américaine ancien employé de facebook
qui défie son ex employeur et qui a
libéré on va dire en fête qui a divulgué
des centaines des milliers de documents
internes à facebook qui met en cause
directement les algorithmes de facebook
et la hiérarchie dont mark zuckerberg
himself on va dire vous pouvez poser
toutes vos questions sur les tchèques du
figaro.fr et sur le chat de youtube ou
faire part de vos remarques est ce que
vous connaissez cette femme est ce que
vous allez suivre cette audition je vous
rappelle qu'elle devrait être auditionné
par les députés de la commission des
affaires économiques et des lois de
l'assemblée nationale d'ici une
vingtaine de minutes maintenant ce sera
évidemment à suivre toujours en direct
sur figaro live mais d'abord je voudrais
qu'on revienne avec océane 1 0
journaliste au figaro économie
sur ces facebook flights en fait sur
l'intégralité en revenir sur les mille
documents qui ont été révélés par
frances hogan mais tous ces documents
externe enfin interne pardon exfiltré
par par frances hogan a qui ont-ils été
donné dans vos premiers temps et que
révèle-t-il on va dire pour la l'immense
majorité d'entre eux les documents ils
ont été donnés dans un premier temps
dans une petite partie des ondes entre
eux un journaliste du wall street
journal qui a été le premier la première
publication à sortir donc les facebook
files à l'époque font face au ghana les
ailes et encore anonyme c'est une
lanceuse dallaire sceaux compte qu'on
n'est pas on connaît pas encore
l'identité elle va la révéler un peu
plus tard dans l'émission 60 minutes aux
états unis donc voilà parés à visage
découvert skis et lance un peu son
son s'était tourné voilà c'est ça sent
sa tournée dans les dents les parlements
européen et aussi américains qu'elle a
été auditionnée au congrès donc après
cette révélation de son identité
une deuxième salve de documents et
révélés dans un certain nombre de médias
et qui permettent d'avoir une vision un
peu plus large en fait de
révélations qu'elle peut faire puisque
des milliers de pages sont sont
divulguées cette fois ci avec un chant
de problématiques abordées plus large
c'est à dire que dans un premier temps
le wall street journal c'est par exemple
concentré sur l'impact de
d l'algorithme d'instagram sur les
jeunes filles l'image qu'elles peuvent
avoir d'elle même ensuite dans la
deuxième salve on a différents documents
qui aborde notamment la la modération
des contenus et les problématiques
auxquelles facebook peut faire face dans
certains pays où on se rend compte que
donc
les états occidentaux ont une modération
qui est bien plus fine que dans certains
pays du sud notamment facebook a
beaucoup de mal par exemple à récupérer
dans les pays qui ne sont pas
anglophones savalas caezar par exemple
les pays en langue arabe c'est très
compliqué pour pour facebook qui n'a pas
des centres de modération partout enfin
dans chaque pays donc c'est difficile de
comprendre les contextes locaux pour les
modérateurs
donc voilà ces différentes
problématiques qui sont abordés par par
ces documents et qui permettent surtout
d'avoir
le regard interne de savoir comment les
salariés de facebook appréhendent ces
difficultés là parce que globalement
c'est des problématiques dont les
observateurs extérieurs avait plus ou
moins conscience mais qu'on avait un peu
de mal à quantifier et c'est un peu ce
que disent aujourd'hui les
parlementaires français qui vont
recevoir français se gagnent c'est bon
mais les problématiques on en avait déjà
conscience mais ce qu'apportent ces
documents c'est de permettre d'attester
que facebook en avez conscience et avec
voix particulièrement ces documents ce
sont des échanges de mails delà de sa
hiérarchie qui lui qui lui qu'il incite
à faire telle ou telle manipulation ou
c'est quoi exactement où c'est des codes
qui qui qui fonctionne sur qu'ils font
fonctionner les algorithmes de facebook
est ce que ce sont précisément ces files
cdml dès qu'est ce que c'est c'est
beaucoup de copies de la cour de du site
de conversation de la plateforme pardon
de conversations internes à l'entreprise
qui s'appelle workplace donc c'est des
échanges entre les salariés par exemple
c'est aussi des enquêtes qui sont menées
en interne parce que facebook emmène un
certain nombre par exemple sur ce qui
concerne les jeunes filles l image
d'elle-même sur instagram
c'est quelque chose qui prend la forme à
peu près d'un powerpoint
donc c'est des études qui sont menées
par des équipes dédiées donc voilà ces
différents types de documents plus ou
moins formalisées en fait et sur
instagram justement parce que ont
évidemment là connu avec sa vue que
c'est le premier papier du du wall
street journal
qu'est ce qui est révélé
particulièrement sur sur les travers on
va dire de l'algorithme d'instagram
particulièrement sur les jeunes femmes
c'est donc ciblé on va dire ce facebook
file oui oui c'est bien en fait ça ça
révèle que fait instagram a tendance à
pousser un certain nombre de contenus
qui vont
amener des jeunes filles à se sentir mal
leur image de l'image de qu'elles ont de
leur corps
après la publication de l'article du
wall street journal il faut savoir que
instagram a publié une une version
annotée des diapositives donc bon je
parlais
pour un peu contesté en fait
l'interprétation qui est faite de
par le wall street journal mais en tout
cas ce que des psychiatres et
psychologues que j'ai interrogés m'ont
dit c'est que ça correspond assez avec
l'interprétation qu'on peut faire de ces
diapositives là c'est que les troubles
de l'image ne sont pas chez les jeunes
s'ils ne sont pas provoqués par
instagram mais instagram va avoir pour
fonction en fait de les renforcer
c'est à dire qu'une jeune fille qui va
toujours chercher des corps émacié des
contenus concernant l'alimentation etc
va se voir proposer ce type de contenu
un peu en boucle
donc facebook enfin comme je disais
instagram à agnetz certaines certaines
des interprétations de ces documents
mais dans le même temps ils ont pris des
mesures suite à l'article du wall street
journal qui vont plutôt dans le sens en
fait des révélations c'est à dire que
une fonctionnalité qui s'appelle t
kubrick
va être instaurée c'est à dire que si un
adolescent passe trop de temps sur sur
son fils instagram instagram l ai
suggéré de prendre une pause ou alors
ils vont ils vont faire du nudge c'est à
dire que s'ils considèrent qu'un
adolescent passe trop de temps sur un
même type de contenu ils vont le pousser
à voir d'autres choses à elle à avoir
d'autres choses sans vraiment le dire
mais c'est voit la csn et ça ce sont des
pistes qui sont sur les rails on va dire
depuis c'est facebook lite on s'était
bien préparée bien en amont c'était pas
en tout cas pas évoqué auparavant donc
on peut penser que c'est vraiment ces
révélations ces révélations la qui les
ont poussés de la même manière ils ont
mis sur pause un autre projet qui
s'appelle instagram fort quitte ce qui
était censé être un réseau social
destinée aux moins de 13 ans et donc en
gros instagram dit on continue de penser
que c'est une bonne idée parce que c'est
quelque chose enfin les enfants sont de
toute manière sur les réseaux sociaux
dont qu autant qu'ils aient quelque
chose qui est là est
spécifiquement dédié qui est design et
pour eux etc mais bon ils ont quand même
décidé de le mettre sur pause après
c'est la publication de cet article là
alors là on discute d'instagram mmmmh
facebook on va dire les travers de
facebook sont connues et sont déjà
révélés depuis un bon bout de temps
maintenant on pense notamment à la
sphère cambridge ali analytica mais
aussi par exemple à un documentaire qui
a eu un écho assez important en france
et dans le monde qui était diffusée sur
netflix qui s'appelait derrière nos
écrans de fumée de sochaux dilemmien en
vo qu'est ce qu'on apprend de plus avec
les facebook live qu'on ne sait déjà pas
avec ce qui s'est passé dans la sphère
cambrai giannetti cas où ce qu'on a
appris dans ce documentaire comme risen
atika ça concernait donc cette cette
société américaine qui a été employé par
par donald trump
pour faire de la campagne publicitaire
pour sa campagne présidentielle de 2016
et qui a qui a récupéré les données de
87 millions d'américains pour l'en but
de lait d'amande et en publicité alors
si leurs fils d'informations sur
facebook ç'a eu beaucoup de
retentissement à l'époque parce que ça
concernait donc une
une élection élections américaines qui
est juste de se dérouler où on
s'interrogeait beaucoup sur l'impact de
facebook
sur les les processus électoraux
maintenant c'est un petit peu moins
c'est un petit peu moins un fait on se
rend compte mon bac ça ça ne se limite
pas au contenu
américain en tout cas la version
américaine de facebook donc on en voit
un peu les répercussions et voilà
quelques mots comme je disais c'est
souvent des choses que les observateurs
extérieurs soupçonnait ou parvenait à un
peu étayés mais maintenant on a vraiment
une vision intérieure par exemple le
lait facebook files évoque le rôle de
facebook dans certains conflits
notamment yanmar
ou en ethiopie dans le cadre de la de la
guerre civile donc ou facebook laisse
passer des contenus madeleine en bouc
qui incitent à la guerre civile qui
avait donc donc voilà c'est facebook
lite permet d'avoir les preuves on va
dire d'une part faire passer pas une
ingérence mais d'un effet on va dire de
la désinformation et parfois d'une
passivité ou d'une incapacité à agir que
frances au grain mais beaucoup sur le
compte de du manque de moyens humains
pour les équipes qui sont spécifiquement
dans le monde et d'y un sens oui
justement elle avait déclaré je ne sais
plus adam khel interview que l'élément
déclencheur en fait pour publier tous
ces documents c'était que sa petite
structure son entité était dissoute
alors que c'était l'entité justement
censé répondre à ce gros problème est
que finalement
la direction mettez de côté on va dire
cet enjeu là c'est ça qui l'avait poussé
à publier c'est comment ces commentaires
alors
évidemment donc bon on le sait
maintenant les algorithmes de facebook
mais instagram aussi c'est pareil c'est
le groupe nourrissent donc la violence
aussi la dépression l'a vu chez chez les
jeunes femmes notamment sur instagram
il ya une formule consacrée dans la dans
la tête mais même dans les médias
maintenant qui dit quand c'est gratuit
c'est que c'est vous le produit c'est
toujours vrai et c'est vraiment ce qui
s'applique aujourd'hui à facebook oui
oui et c'est c'est quelque chose c'est
une formule que
francis hogan reprend de manière un peu
modifiée c'est à dire qu'elle elle
répète assez souvent que facebook mais
les profits avant les gens enfin place
les projets les profils avant les gens
c'est quelque chose que mark zuckerberg
évidemment réfuté dans un mémo qui elle
a transmis aux salariés de facebook il a
qualifié de non sens
mais parallèlement voilà il a aussi pris
les mesures que j'ai évoqué plus tôt
concernant instagram et d'autres
notamment hier avec l'annoncé d'une
volonté de limiter
le ciblage publicitaire en fonction de
certains critères notamment
l'affinité politique
l'appartenance ethnique l'orientation
sexuelle donc toutes ces choses on est
trop avons écrit limiter à l'avenir il a
réagi publiquement sur ses facebook live
dans les nommés en les nommant en
nommant français se gagnent ou où il a
laissé le soin à son entreprise de faire
un communiqué est ce que quelle est la
réponse de marc zuckerberg a toute ses
tourments que rencontre son entreprise
dans l'immédiat et il n'a pas hélas pas
réagi publiquement il a réagit donc via
un mémo adressé à ses salariés
mais est publiée qui a été bien vertes
et presse je ne sais plus s'il était
publié exactement sur le sur le site
enfin sur un site officiel mais en tout
cas il était voilà il a été transmis
dans la presse
et voilà c'est quelque chose qui n'a pas
évoqué
directement dans un type d'allocation
comme on pouvait peut-être s'y attendre
mais quand il a présenté donc mais tu as
donc qui est là le nouveau nom de
facebook en tant qu en tant que groupe
il n'a pas non plus évoqué nommément
france c'est son gagne pain ça reste ça
reste quelque chose qui est qu'il laisse
un peu à distance et voilà justement le
fait de renommer facebook de donner cet
nouvel élan en disant on va développer
le métavers cetc a pu être vue comme une
manière de tourner la page des
polémiques et donc d'entamer dont
quelque chose plus d'orienter vers le
futur même si c'était pas exactement ce
sujet mais c'était quelque chose qui
était déjà évidemment en gestation
depuis plusieurs mois voire années pour
développer cette ce nouveau pas en fait
de l'activité de facebook qui va être
donc la réalité virtuelle c'est aussi un
moyen de détourner l'attention sur la
mauvaise presse qu'a facebook en ce
moment qu'elle est qu on va dire
juridique ces révélations ont-elles eu
le gendarme de la bourse américaine
a été prévenue a reçu tous ces dossiers
est ce qui va à tenter quelque chose
contre contre facebook en tout cas les
législateurs américains
commencent à s'emparer de sujets là il
ya quelque chose que frances hogan
critique beaucoup c'est l'algorithme fin
de celle la curation des contenus sur la
base de l'engagement c'est à dire que
facebook va prioriser dans un fil
d'actualités des contenus avec lesquels
on a le plus de chances d'interagir
c'est à dire assez souvent pas des
choses qui est bon soit nous choquer
soit nous énerver soit nouveau rendre
triste fin bref quelque chose qui va
provoquer une émotion et vont pousser à
réagir à interagir avec le contenu donc
frances hogan dit que ça c'est un peu ça
un peu mortifère c'est à dire que ça va
toujours poussé des contenus qui sont
choquants énervant
donc elle ce qu'elle propose assez
régulièrement c'est de donner le choix
aux utilisateurs d'avoir un contenu
chronologique c'est à dire que le fils
va être ordonnée de manière à ce que ce
soit les postes les plus récents qui
apparaissent en premier
et ça c'est quelque chose par exemple
qui est proposée par par twitter mais
qui
selon elle devrait être proposée plus
tôt à l'utilisateur de manière à ce
qu'ils aient vraiment choix et que ce
soit pas une option aller chercher ps
qui aurait fait un billet aussi utiliser
cet album rythme là puisque n'importe
quel contenu le plus neuf peu importe sa
validité on va dire sa fiabilité serait
mis en avant juste parce qu'il est plus
frais c'est aussi un autre travers non
oui c'est possible c'est vrai quand on
est un peu
à la phase un peu de recherche
d'amélioration des avis de ce contenu
très très réglée par l'algorithme qu'est
ce qu'on peut proposer d'autres et du
coup les
législateurs américains commencent à se
pencher dessus avec un
un texte qui va être examinée pour
proposer une vision justement in avons
un algorithme qui ne dépendent pas en
fait d'un
[Musique]
fonctionnement là
devant les eurodéputés lundi elle a
déclaré je cite une autre citation on a
entendu un extrait tout à l'heure en
direct mais elle a déclaré aussi que
quand les activités commerciales entre
en conflit avec les intérêts de la
société dans son ensemble les
démocraties doivent intervenir et faire
de nouvelles lois donc à l'appel
clairement les députés à à légiférer a
comme vous disiez elle a dénoncé etc
mais est-ce que elle préconise des
solutions lors de ses interventions dont
les députés devant les eurodéputés par
exemple elle a salué le courage donc des
lois dont vous parliez qui sont en ce
moment en débat au parlement européen
elle a dit que ce serait une bonne idée
peut-être même un bon modèle pour les
états unis mais est-ce qu'elle a des
solutions à apporter à ce problème de
l'algue ory parce qu'elle a réfléchi je
dis donc il ya ce que j'ai évoqué le
fait de mettre fin au classement fondé
sur l'engagement mais il ya aussi
d'autres nologie voilà il ya aussi
d'autres choses qu'elles qu'elles
proposent notamment quelque chose qui
revient assez souvent qui est que
facebook publié les recherches qu'il
mène auprès de ses utilisateurs et de
l'impact de de ces plateformes de
manière à ce que les chercheurs
extérieurs puissent avoir accès à des
données puissent
faire ça de manière un peu plus un peu
plus libre
parce qu'elle le dit souvent
elle disait être choqués du fait que
personne extérieure à facebook ne sait
vraiment ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
et donc ça ce serait un moyen d'engager
vers plus de transparence
et aussi de manière un peu plus un peu
plus nette elle elle indiqué à lisbonne
que selon elle marc zuckerberg est tout
simplement démissionner pour être
remplacé par quelqu'un qui selon elle
donne la priorité à la sécurité
donc voilà ça elle accuse directement
mark zuckerberg est à l'origine on va
dire de ça on va en tout cas d'avoir un
réel pouvoir
de nuisance entre guillemets sûr sûr sûr
les utiliser la sécurité des
utilisateurs dans facebook c'est ça oui
lll le visa c'est directement et est
encore au parlement européen lundi
interrogé justement sur les annonces de
mark zuckerber concernant metal un peu à
railler cette tentative de rebond en
disant que si facebook avait les moyens
de métal du cou avait les moyens de
recruter tant de personnes pour
développer un méta vert c'est assez
paradoxal que ya pas assez de personnes
pour modérer voilà modérés tout
simplement donc le pont sait exactement
combien il ya de personnes pour modérer
annoncé un chiffre qui n'est pas rendu
public il existe peut-être je les pages
des pentes à vous et alors bon alors ça
c'est sûr les solutions qu'elle
préconise mais est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
solutions qui sont possibles c'est un
problème comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure qui existe depuis longtemps le
les travers de la big tech et des
algorithmes
avant que ça démarre dans 5 minutes est
ce qu'il ya d'autres pistes pour réguler
cet empire
facebook c'est un hébergeur donc ce
n'est pas vraiment responsable des
déconvenues en gros qui sont publiés
sur les plateformes une méthode du coût
à part si on lui signale donc certains
législateurs essaye de rendre les
plateformes plus responsable de ce
qu'elles peuvent ce qu'elles peuvent
héberger on a notamment de laëtitia
vient en france députés qui avaient
tenté de via une loi de pousser les
plateformes à
censurer les contenus manifestement
illicite dans un délai de 24 heures ça a
été censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel qui est jugé qu'il y
avait un risque en gros de
d'atteinte à la liberté d'expression en
supprimant trop vite ou voilà en
agissant trop rapidement donc là encore
c'est difficile en fait dans d'imposer
des règles qui ne soit pas attentatoire
à la liberté d'expression sur sur ses
plates formes là il ya une autre
proposition qui revient assez souvent
c'est tout simplement le démantèlement
des gars femmes et les a même pas très
réaliste c'est cette plus ambitieux il
ya eu des films sont des précédents pour
d'autres c'est une entreprise de
démantèlement aux états unis donc c'est
pas quelque chose de tout à fait baroque
chez eux mais voilà c'était portée par
une personnalité comme elizabeth warren
donc candidate à la présidentielle s'est
éprise démocrate
et la nationalisation de ce type
d'entreprises non c'est encore plus
baroques comme solution c'est assez peu
évoqués je vais vente dans l'immédiat
pourquoi pas on présente on donne de
séduction dans quelques instants donc
regarder la commission des affaires
économiques et des lois est en place on
va vous laisser regarder cette audition
qui est traduite par l'assemblée
nationale je remercie mon invité au cnr
héros jura sache vous êtes journaliste
au figaro économie on lit tous vos
papiers sur lefigaro.fr et dans les
pages du figaro
je vous laisse regarder donc cette
audition sur figaro live et cet après
midi francis hogan sera également
auditionné par le sénat en fin
d'après-midi à très vite sur figaro live
et bonne écoute
plutôt en avance je pense sur ce sujet
la directive e-commerce a établi dès
l'an 2000 un régime de responsabilité
limitée des hébergeurs tenue de
supprimer les contenus illégaux qui leur
sont signalés mais la place croissante
de ses réseaux dans le monde
et surtout dans la vie quotidienne des
citoyens du monde plus de 3 milliards
d'utilisateurs mensuels pour les trois
applications que je viens de mentionner
leur impact sur le fonctionnement des
démocraties notamment en période
électorale une va bientôt s'ouvrir ici
nous avons suivi l'impact de ces réseaux
sociaux sur les élections aux états unis
en 2016 dans 2020 interroge des
responsables politiques en europe en
france particulièrement et plus
généralement dans tous les pays
respectueux des droits de l'homme est
attachée aux droits libres et éclairés
de leurs citoyens
les députés français ici présents vont
vous faire part de ses nombreuses
interrogations pour ma part je débuterai
cette audition en vous posant trois
questions
comme je les dis les critiques à
l'encontre de facebook ou mettant selon
la nouvelle dénomination du groupe ne
sont pas récentes
l'intérêt de votre témoignage résulte
évidemment du fait que vous avez
travaillé pour ce groupe que vous
connaissez de l'intérieur ce léviathan
moderne dont chacun sait que la
transparence n'est pas sa raison d'être
mais qui ne ne pas être perçue non plus
comme le méchant loup grand méchant loup
je note d'ailleurs que dans une tribune
publiée hier par le journal le monde
vous l'avez sans doute lui madame monica
big hurt vice-président de meta plaide
pour que les gouvernements démocratiques
définissent de nouvelles règles pour
internet dans des domaines tels que les
contenus nuisibles la protection de
vitry blé ou l'intégrité des élections
dans les plantes que vous avez déposé et
vous affirmer que facebook induit les
investisseurs en erreur pour donner la
priorité à sa croissance sur la sécurité
pourriez vous nous préciser en quoi
facebook fait primer ses intérêts
économiques sur le rôle sociétal qui
devrait aussi d'idées cette activité ma
seconde question découle de la première
si vous considérez que facebook ne
remplit pas les obligations qu'ils
devraient être les siennes c'est que
vous vous référez à un modèle somme tout
idéal dès lors comment devrait selon
vous fonctionner un réseau social idéal
estimez-vous que facebook puisse se
plier à ce modèle que vous préconisez
vous pensez vous possible de voir
émerger des réseaux alternatifs
fonctionnant selon vos voeux et enfin
l'actualité récente a montré que les
états peuvent s'entendre pour imposer
une taxation minimale sur les gérants du
numérique et je pense qu'on peut ici se
féliciter du fait que la france et
l'europe ait été à la manoeuvre pour
mettre en place cette taxation des
géants du numérique et au delà des
multinationales qui montre qu'on peut
s'entendre au niveau international pour
faire face à des entreprises qui elles
le sont devenus également
et donc la régulation internationale des
réseaux sociaux et sans doute aussi du
domaine du possible lors de votre
intervention devant la commission du
commerce du sénat des états unis vous
avez vous même effectué une comparaison
avec l'industrie du tabac pour inciter
les autorités gouvernementales à
intervenir dès lors je souhaiterais
connaître votre opinion sur les projets
européens actuellement en discussion
digital makada digital servait sacd et
mads 1 étant précisé que nous avons ici
les collègues de la commission des lois
en sont bien conscients d'ores et déjà
transcrite en droit français une partie
de ces dispositions madame la présidente
de la commission des lois cyrielle vous
avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président de
la commission des affaires économiques
cheikh roland mes chers collègues madame
francis haugen la commission des lois
est également très heureuse de pouvoir
vous entendre aujourd'hui en effet la
commission que je préside la commission
compétente en ce qui concerne le régime
des lanceurs d'alert au titre de sa
compétence en matière de libertés
publiques et de droits fondamentaux
d'ailleurs et c'est une coïncidence
heureuse c'est tout à l'heure que la
commission des lois va examiner la
proposition de loi et la proposition de
loi organique de monsieur sylvain va
zermane visant à améliorer la protection
des lanceurs d'alerté dont l'objet est
notamment de transposer en droit
français la directive européenne du 23
octobre 2019 sur les lanceurs d'alert
cette proposition de loi se nourrit
également des travaux de contrôle de
notre commission le rapport d'évaluation
de la sapin de effectué par raphaël
gauvin et olive démarre l'ex loi votée
en 2016 qui avait consacré les lanceurs
d'alerté cette mission d'évaluation a
consacré un large volet à la situation
actuelle des danseurs d'alert en france
le constat est partagé la question des
lanceurs d'alert occupe une place de
plus en plus grande dans le débat public
mais reste un concept juridique
difficile à manier c'est si les
allemands peuvent être un outil de
détection de dysfonctionnements internes
d'infraction et d'atteinte à l'intérêt
général notamment dans le domaine de la
corruption de l'environnement mais ils
ne doivent pas être détourné pour porter
atteinte à la présomption d'innocence ou
contourner les règles encadrant la
liberté d'expression en 2016 donc le
législateur français a voulu définir ce
qu'était un lanceur d alerte il a
encadré les procédures de signalement et
a prévu des protections contre les
représailles dont ils pourraient faire
l'objet le droit français exigent le
désintéressement et la bonne foi du
lanceur d'alerté privilégie les
signalements en interne avant toute
divulgation publique donc à cet égard il
serait intéressant que vous nous
expliquiez le fonctionnement des
lanceurs d'alerté aux états unis et
notamment est-ce que vous avez par
exemple été rémunéré dans le cadre de l'
alerte que vous avez lancé les règles
françaises ont largement inspiré l'union
européenne qui est adoptée en octobre
2019 une directive visant à harmoniser
au niveau européen la protection donner
aux lanceurs d'alert de nombreux pays ne
dispose pas encore d'un régime
spécifique et de ce point de vue la
france peut se féliciter d'être à
l'avant garde
malheureusement si les mentalités
évoluent de nombreuses administrations
et entreprises restent réticentes à
traiter efficacement en interne des
signalements qui parfois les embarrasse
les moyens dont dispose le défenseur des
droits pour accompagner les lanceurs
d'alert reste également insuffisant les
lanceurs d'alert font souvent l'objet de
représailles et de procédures dites
bâillon contre lesquels les justes les
juges reste souvent démunis ils
rencontrent parfois de graves
difficultés financières et personnelles
c'est pourquoi nous devons poursuivre
nos efforts donc la transposition de la
directive de 2019 sous la forme de
proposition de loi que nous allons
examinez juste après l'audition que nous
effectuons ce matin avec vous va
corriger nombreux de ses défauts je
pense notamment aux chants des
informations susceptibles de faire
l'objet d'une alerte à la possibilité de
faire une divulgation publique sans
passer au préalable par un canal interne
ou de la protection contre les risques
de représailles j'observe que de très
nombreuses dispositions de la
proposition de loi trouve une résonance
dans les signalements que vous avez fait
qui constitue pour nous une sorte de cas
pratiques donc votre audition sera très
éclairante pour nos travaux car lorsque
l'on naît lorsque l'on élabore un
nouveau régime juridique il est utile de
savoir ce que font nos voisins et
partenaires et de s'interroger pour
savoir si une alerte de l'ampleur que
celle que vous avez lancé aurait pu
avoir lieu dans notre pays donc moi je
serais intéressé par effectivement le
fait de savoir si ce que vous pensez par
rapport à la rémunération des lanceurs
d'alerté aux états unis et si vous dans
le cas particulier qui est le vôtre vous
avez reçu une rémunération est ce que
vous avez également une inquiétude par
rapport à d'éventuelles représailles
et quels sont les protections dont vous
pouvez bénéficier à titre personnel à
titre psychologique est ce que vous
bénéficiez d'un accompagnement parce que
l'on sait que la situation d'un lanceur
d' alerte peut être tu es très délicate
sur le plan professionnel et personnel
et que le rôle des législateurs que nous
sommes sont de vous assurer une
protection la plus complète possible et
donc il sera intéressant de voir quel
est votre vécu par rapport à cela et
quelle est la protection vous pouvez
donc vous pouvez bénéficier dans le
système américain donc ce que je vous
propose c'est de procéder donc à un
propos liminaire de répondre aux
questions de monsieur le président
lescure et de moi même et puis
évidemment vous voyez qu'il y à de très
nombreux collègues du parlement français
qui sont venus pour assister à votre
audition ce matin et qu'ils seront très
intéressé par vos réponses et puis qui
souhaiteront vous poser de très
nombreuses questions je n'en doute pas
donc madame à horgen vous avez la parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
d'un qu'il ferait a priori je remercie
de me donner l'opportunité de
comparaître devant vous et je vous
remercie de l'intérêt que vous montrez
de faire face à l'une des menaces les
plus importantes pour la france je suis
fatigué je travaille chez facebook et
j'ai rejoint cette entreprise parce que
je pense que facebook a le potentiel de
faire ressortir de ce qu'il ya de mieux
en nous néanmoins je suis ici parce que
je pense que les produits de facebook
nuisent aux enfants attiser les
divisions et affaiblissent les
démocraties et bien plus encore
or l'entreprise c'est comment rendre
ses activités plus sûr mais elle ne le
ferons pas parce qu'elle met toujours
les profits colossaux avant la sécurité
des usagers la plate forme aujourd'hui
nuit à la santé à la sécurité de nos
communautés et nuit également
l'intégrité de nos communautés afin de
soulever relever ces défis il faudra
faire face à des difficultés mais les
démocraties doivent faire ce qu'elles
ont toujours fait lorsque les activités
commerciales ont un impact sur la
sécurité
des communautés et des populations il
faut que de nouvelles lois soient mis en
place et je suis reconnaissante au
gouvernement français de prendre ce
sujet accord à coeur je sais que vous
avez beaucoup oeuvré pour lutter contre
la désinformation et j'espère que la
pression continuera pour protéger les
lanceurs d'alertés aimez analyser mes
explications des documents qui ont été
révélés a créé beaucoup de temps j'ai
travaillé dans de grandes entreprises
depuis 2006 technologiques y compris
google print et reste et alpes et
facebook mon travail s'est concentré sur
les produits algorithmique et comme
google crosscheck et des systèmes
recommandé comme celui qui permet au fil
d'actualités de google de fonctionner au
cours de ce travail j'ai pu comparer la
façon dont chaque entreprise essaie de
relever des défis et les choix au sein
de facebook sont très problématique pour
les enfants pour la sécurité publique
pour la démocratie et c'est pourquoi je
m'exprime
mais soyons clairs
les choses n'ont pas être ainsi nous
sommes ici aujourd'hui parce que
facebook a fait des choix délibéré j'ai
rejoint facebook en 2019 parce que
quelqu'un de proche à s'est radicalisé
en ligne et je me suis senti obligé de
prendre un de jouer un rôle actif pour
que facebook soit moins toxiques au
cours de mon travail chez facebook en
tant que chef de produit et puis ensuite
dans la cellule quand tu nages j'ai
remarqué que facebook fait toujours
primer ses intérêts financiers avant la
sécurité
par conséquent ceci attiser les
divisions les extrêmes et la
polarisation
cela nuit aux sociétés partout dans le
monde et parfois cela peut même mener à
la violence et au décès de certaines
personnes
très souvent les systèmes algorithmiques
permettent de générer davantage de haine
notamment en visant les populations les
plus vulnérables
et il ne s'agit pas ici simplement dans
problème lié à la colère ou à
l'instabilité de certains utilisateurs
des réseaux sociaux
google
est devenu une entreprise qui pèse des
milliers de milliards de dollars et ce
sur le dos de la sécurité c'est quelque
chose d'inacceptable je pense que ce que
j'ai fait quelque chose de bien pour le
bien public
et
je me suis exprimée par ce que je
reconnais cette menace personne
pratiquement en dehors de facebook c'est
ce qui se passe
facebook et voilà pourquoi la protection
des lanceurs d'alerté 6 qui fondamentale
les dirigeants
gardent des informations secrètes ne les
divulgue pas à l'extérieur les documents
qui ont été fournis montre que facebook
nous à maintes et maintes fois trompé
et était tout à fait au courant de la
semaine nuisibles de ses activités
notamment vers les enfants il faut donc
de nouvelles normes de nouvelles règles
et une union européenne à un potentiel
énorme en la matière je ne faut pas
simplement essayé de balayer ce problème
de la main mais il faut prendre ce
problème à bras le corps et je soutiens
totalement la proche de l'union
européenne je pense que de nouvelles
lois
dépendent également de la volonté des
états membres de les faire appliquer
facebook et d'autres entreprises autres
plateformes importantes représente un
risque pour les sociétés pour la
démocratie
j'aimerais souligner quelques points qui
à mon avis sans clé tout d'abord il faut
que ces entreprises puissent rendre des
comptes et il faut également de
nouvelles règles de ce business model
nous comprenons les choix destructeur
encore mieux que facebook et facebook ne
peut pas rester juge jury procurèrent et
témoin à fois donc le point de départ
important ici c'est la transparence
et les données les recherches sur les
données doivent se poursuivre il faut
que toutes les données nécessaires
soient recueillies pour pouvoir
avoir une approche éclairé j'ai
promu une approche en trois étapes c'est
le plan en deux trois premières étapes
chaque plateforme devrait pouvoir rendre
des comptes sur les risques
elle devrait faire des analyses de
produits et être forcé à faire ses
analyses deuxièmement
le public et la société civile doivent
être
examinées pour voir au sens
facebook est très loin de l'asie par
exemple il faut s'assurer que
l'évaluation des lits risque dépeint un
tableau
général de la situation
d'autre part il faut que chaque action
nuisible soient ciblées par le biais
d'un plan et dans le cadre de ce plan il
faut posséder les données nécessaires
pour avancer
et il faut s'assurer que des chaudes
soit vraiment fait pour aller de l'avant
a toujours essayé de se justifier en
disant nous travaillons sur le problème
or cela doit changer tout cela commence
par l'accès aux données l'une des
questions les plus récurrentes était
quel type de données doit-on demander à
facebook eh bien
il faut pouvoir avoir accès à l'ensemble
des données facebook
deux façons
néanmoins précautionneuse pour ne pas
nuire à la protection des données
incident les régulateurs auraient la
possibilité
d'évaluer les risques
les preuves de que j'ai retrouvé dans le
cadre de mon travail montre qu'il est
important de pouvoir provoquer une
réaction
des risques systémiques des réseaux
sociaux sont
évidents il s'agit ici d'un problème au
niveau système est utilisé des
outils et de nouvelles lois pour contrer
cela devrait pouvoir aider les
plateformes à contrer la manipulation
des élections la désinformation ou de
nuire aux adolescents
si les règles et les lois sont bien les
dictées alors un changement est vraiment
possible
et les plateformes
rendront des comptes sur le risque
qu'elle provoque est ainsi elle ne se
contentera pas simplement des regarder
les profits il faut mettre en place des
normes qui puisse assurer une protection
et montrer que la transparence et que la
surveillance peuvent fonctionner
n'oublions pas que nous avons déjà été
un croisement des chemins auparavant
il fut un temps où on disait que des
cigarettes avec des filtres été
meilleure pour la santé que des
cigarettes sans filtre et néanmoins ces
cigarettes continuer à poser un risque
en fait c'était même plus toxiques parce
que
d'importants de s'attaquer à la racine
du problème
et il est impossible
d'avoir accès aux données de la société
alors comment le public est il sensé
la santé n'ont pas de la santé mentale
je joue je veux parler ici et prendre un
exemple très français il y a une page
qui compte huit millions et demi
d'abonnés dans ce pays avec un nom
parfaitement à d'autres à noda santé
plus magazine et des publications qui
sont abjects parfois moralement je vous
en cite une parmi d'autres datent d'hier
9 choses dégoûtantes que font les femmes
sans jamais l'avouer et puis des
publications qui parfois sont
extrêmement dangereuses pour la santé je
voudrais savoir si ces pages là sont
modérés et régulée et dans quelles
conditions merci merci avec samba louis
pour le groupe agir
merci monsieur le président
votre parcours votre engagement nous ont
profondément marqué du fait de leur
ampleur puisqu'il vous oppose la une des
plus puissantes entreprises du monde
mais également par les enjeu
démocratique que vous avez mis en avant
à juste titre ben oui pardon j'ai juste
changé de micro parce que sinon on verra
votre dos
merci à daisy je reprends votre parcours
votre engagement nous ont profondément
marqué du fait de leur ampleur puisqu'il
vous oppose l une des plus puissantes
entreprises du monde mais également par
les enjeu démocratique que vous avez mis
en avant à juste titre sont des défis
majeurs pour nos démocraties
notre présidente de la commission des
lois la rappeler notre commission se
penchera juste après cette audition sur
la proposition de loi relative à la
protection de lanceurs d'alertés je
remercie à ce titre dans le ballon et
notre objectif est clair il s'agit
d'offrir une meilleure protection
lanceur d' alerte mais aussi au
facilitateur
vous l'avez rappelé vous vous êtes
beaucoup exposé est justement par
rapport à ces facilitateurs qui vont en
partie accompagner dans votre parcours
vous êtes appuyé donc sur ces
facilitateurs dont le rôle doit être
particulièrement souligné pouvez vous
nous préciser quels étaient leurs rôles
dans votre parcours
ah bon nous tenons également être au
fait notre système et à bâtir un modèle
solide l'interrogation que je sois très
portés au nom du groupe agir ensemble
concernant votre combat contre les
responsabilités éthiques de facebook et
des soldes solution vous envisagez pour
répondre à cette problème tic centrale
qui touche à nos libertés fondamentales
vous dénoncez l'action du groupe de mark
zuckerberg est plutôt son inaction dans
la défense de la sécurité de ses usagers
vous avez souligné le manque de moyens
investis pour faire face à cet enjeu ce
qui est d'autant plus surprenante
puisque facebook n'a jamais connu de
résultats financiers aussi élevé avec
plus de 29 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires soit une hausse de 17% vous
dites clairement ils ont mis le profit
avant la sécurité vous avez récemment
déclaré au guardian vouloir lancer une
organisation soutenant la réforme des
médias sociaux quelles actions concrètes
mais n'dré vous pour lutter contre l'
irresponsabilité éthique au sein de
facebook et plus généralement pour
endiguer le caractère addictif et les
risques de harcèlement intrinsèque à ces
plateformes menace que vous avez
évoquées au cours de plusieurs
entretiens
une dernière question vous avez vos
quêtes il élimine les dangers auxquels
facebook expose les enfants pourriez
vous nous préciser l'aider je voudrais
terminer en vous remerciant pour votre
courage merci philippe dunoyer pour le
groupe udi indépendant merci monsieur le
président en est la présidente mes chers
collègues madame le front ne se
souvienne je voudrais également comme
mes collègues vous saluer votre courage
et vous remercier pour le travail et les
informations considérable que vous nous
apportez vous avez déjà porté depuis
plusieurs mois elles sont
terrifiantes quand on l'aimé bien en
ligne ce qui est surtout terrifiant
c'est de constater que dans une
entreprise aussi gigantesque celle de
facebook il a fallu vous attendre pour
que alors que des dizaines et des
centaines de milliers de salariés y
travaillent les comportements que vous
dénoncez nous soient connus fit donc mes
questions elles sont évidemment dans la
droite ligne de l'examen de notre
proposition de loi sur la protection des
lanceurs d'alerté que nous aurons à
coeur
d'examiner tout à l'heure elles sont de
droit niveau d'abord sur la pression
interne pour comprendre selon votre
point de vue comment
on peut se faire que vous soyez la seule
à avoir eu non seulement le courage mais
la capacité de dénoncer ce que vous nous
donner comme information et comme ce
texte de loi propose des procédures de
signalement interne pensez-vous
raisonnable faisable cale entre à
l'intérieur d'une entreprise comme
facebook un signalement interne se met
en place
au niveau deuxième question de la
coopération internationale puisque
chaque état est finalement bien bien
dépendant et bien et bien avant et bien
fragile face à la puissance d'une
entreprise comme facebook pensez-vous
utile nécessaire et là aussi faisable
que les états non seulement à l'échelle
européenne à l'échelle internationale
puisse organiser les dispositifs à la
fois de protection et de transparence
que vous avez pointé du doigt juste
titre tout à l'heure pour ces géants qui
organise nos vies quotidiennes et puis
enfin une question un peu plus
personnelle probablement quel est l'avis
d'une lanceuse d' alerte après l' alerte
lancée
c'est évidemment bien sûr sans rentrer
dans un niveau tout à fait personnelle
des questions qui nous qui nous taraude
puisque on imagine que cette vie n'est
pas simple mais pouvez-vous nous donner
quelques témoignages qui nous
permettrait de comprendre comment ce
dispositif de protection peut
s'accompagner d'un protêt une protection
plus personnel merci olivier falorni
pour le groupe liberté territoire
allez-y
merci monsieur le président madame hogen
depuis que vous avez claqué la porte de
facebook les révélations sur ce réseau
social se succèdent parmi celles-ci
facebook savait que des régimes
autoritaires contrôler leurs dissidents
grâce à sa plate forme et n'a rien fait
facebook savait que ses algorithmes
devenu d'une telle complexité
échappe à son propre contrôle et n'a
rien fait et obsédé par sa croissance
l'entreprise s'est octroyé pour mission
de connecter tout à chacun dans le monde
sans jamais se donner les moyens de
modérer ses contenus alors naturellement
nous sommes inquiets évidemment nous
appelons à une meilleure régulation des
contenus et sur cette question votre
avis en tant que ex perte des données
des algorithmes nous sera
particulièrement précieux
alors les documents internes
que vous avez révélé montre un manque de
moyens humains et financiers
dédiés à la modération des contenus un
accroissement des moyens et une
réorganisation
suffirait-il vraiment à faire face aux
déviances des réseaux faudrait-il par
exemple imposer à facebook de publier le
nombre de contenus retirer ou de
modérateur par pays ou par langues
l'europe travaille un digital services
act quelles mesures faut-il mettre en
place selon vous dans ce cadre pour
accroître la transparence et la
régularité la régulation des algorithmes
une autre voie explorée et la régulation
économique et même le démantèlement des
géants du numérique y êtes-vous
favorable
en fait pour conclure tout bonnement
comment nous y prendre pour réguler son
compte à facebook
merci ugo bernalicis à ça va être dur à
traduire quand même monsieur falorni
donc hugo bernalicis pour le groupe
france est soumise
merci merci madame au grain pour votre
votre témoignage et surtout pour l'
alerte que vous avez lancé au monde au
monde entier puisque nous sommes toutes
et toutes concernées vu la puissance du
réseau social et des réseaux sociaux
gérée par facebook moi j'ai deux deux
questions la première c'est lié aux
lanceurs d'alert
il y as en discussion dans la loi que
vous en discutez monsieur à travers le
monde la question de l'asile politique
et de l'asile qui pourraient être
offerts à des lanceurs d alerte à
travers le monde qui pourrait être
persécutés dans leur pays je pense
notamment aux cas de julian assange qui
a ému beaucoup de monde on a été un
certain nombre à défendre le fait qu'il
fallait qu'ils obtiennent l'asile mais
il n'est pas prévu aujourd'hui dans les
textes que aux titres de dette relanceur
d' alerte on puisse être avoir avoir
l'asile est ce que vous pensez que ça
puisse être une piste intéressante pour
faire émerger des lanceurs d alerte dans
des pays où il n'y a pas actuellement de
régime pour les pour les protéger ça
c'est la première question la deuxième
c'est finalement de votre expérience à
l'intérieur de facebook est ce que vous
pensez vraiment qu'il est encore
possible de changer quelques choses de
l'intérieur j'ai vu que vous aviez
plutôt plaidé finalement pour renforcer
les contrôles dits externes est ce que
il ne faut pas uniquement augmenter ses
contrôles externes quitte à taxer les
gens du numérique pour financer ce
contrôle externe indépendant et qui
puisse être à la main des états en tout
cas des démocraties et finalement est ce
que le combat qui est celui d'un certain
nombre d ong d'associations pour obliger
les réseaux sociaux à
l'interopérabilité de leurs données
est-ce que c'est pas le cadre juridique
qu'il faudrait mettre en place et
ensuite contrôlé par un véritable
contrôle externe effectif pour aboutir à
une pacification on va dire de ces
réseaux sociaux en tout cas faire en
sorte qu'il ne puisse pas être nuisible
aux individus et aux démocraties merci
merci à tous et à toutes je pense qu'on
a fait le tour des orateurs groupe
non finalement il ya madame du ce n'est
pas là donc voilà miss haugen times
vous pouvez évidemment regrouper vos
réponses si vous le souhaitez merci à
vous
m
sow
commençons avec
ce qui nous a amenés ici aujourd'hui
qu'elle a été la série de choix qui est
défait par facebook et pourquoi facebook
at il fait ses choix j'essaye toujours
de ne pas critiquer des individus ou
alors d'essayer de leur attribuer des
motifs parce qu'en fait le problème ici
c'est le système du système facebook et
ses produits les deux sont liés donc le
premier problème à facebook c'est que
facebook n'a pas de système de
responsabilité interne très souvent les
porte-parole de facebook ont refusé de
donner des noms lorsqu'on leur demande
qui est responsable de la décision quant
au contenu instinct g pour les enfants
par exemple qui est responsable pour eux
des spécificités à chaque fois facebook
répond en disant mais ce ne sont pas des
individus qui décide ce sont des
communautés
donc j'ai encouragé
par exemple pour ce qui est du ds à aux
autres d'essayer d'attacher un nom à
chaque changement à chaque prise de
décision parce que c'est prise de
décision seulement des conséquences sur
des milliers et des milliers de
personnes et je pense que si un nom été
attribués à ces actions il y aurait plus
de responsabilités ne faut pas
refuser
la réalité facebook a un pouvoir
extraordinaire
beaucoup de personnes
qui sont impliquées et facebook elle ce
concept qui dit que tout le monde tout
tous les gens sont égaux au sein de
facebook
ils pensent que s'ils peuvent choisir
les bonnes
mesures alors les gens pourront faire ce
qu'ils veulent mais le problème ce sont
les mesures elle-même vie sont les
données elles mêmes et en 2000 18
facebook a essayé de
de maximiser le nombre d'interactions
sur facebook mais ça n'a pas été un bon
pour nous il appelle cela des
interactions sociales
qui font sens mais en fait vous pouvez
avoir des intimidations etc rien ou
alors de la colère exprimée sur internet
qui sont relayés et donc plusieurs
langues
lors ce qu'ils ont fait cela en quelques
mois les partis politiques en europe on
dit à facebook beaucoup de partis
politiques partout sur le continent j'en
dis nous savons vous avez changé les
algorithmes parce qu autrefois on
pouvait publier des
livres blancs par exemple sur notre
politique agricole des faits et la
distribution se passer mais aujourd'hui
si on ne pose pas à l'idée donner
polarisantes
on n'est pas entendus il n'y a que le
silence on entend que les cris qui
donc nos options étaient influencés par
les algorithmes de facebook et ceci est
inacceptable parce que nos démocraties
doivent être fondées sur ce que veulent
les gens pas sur ce que les algorithmes
de facebook souhaite alors pourquoi
facebook a mis en place ce système
facebook
très souvent a dit
qu'il
ne souhaite pas on être au point un
système qui sème la colère et bien sûr
il ne le souhaite pas mais il savait
qu'elles étaient les risques et les
conséquences ils ont tout fait pour que
les gens créent davantage
et pour donner des petits coups de
dopamine à chaque fois que vous aviez un
like un commentaire à ce moment là vous
étiez plus à même de produire davantage
de contenu pour facebook donc on ne peut
pas entendre cette justification de
facebook qui dit qu'il voulait maximiser
le bien-être parce que
on s'est rendu compte après que les
changements ont été mis en place que
les
résultats étaient négatifs et il est
question ici de la possibilité de
facebook de mou maculé sur le long terme
il ya eu des questions également sur le
marché c'est un marché que nous avons
des systèmes d'eau
d'interopérabilité par email vous pouvez
avoir votre propre serveur vos propres
clients le marché peut améliorer les
emails mais l'inter opérabilité ne
fonctionnera pas parfois pour facebook
et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
cette idée d'interopérabilité c'est à
dire je peux être sur facebook où le
plaçant les gens veulent cela parce que
facebook a montré très clairement qu'ils
n'ont pas le leadership qui leur
permettent d'avoir autant de
responsabilités que nécessaire mais tous
leurs amis sont dessus dans les réseaux
sociaux
qui se sont diffusées par exemple tik
tok dans ses réseaux sociaux là ils
veulent simplement atteindre le plus de
personnes possible
donc il ya des gens qui copient leur
contenu tik tok pour le mettre sur
youtube c'est comme ça que fonctionne le
marché pour les réseaux sociaux diffusée
mais pour ce qui est des réseaux sociaux
personnels on essaye de toucher des
personnes en particulier donc si je ne
peux pas envoyer mon contenu à mon ami
je ne vais pas poster quoi que ce soit
sur le réseau social donc pour revenir
l'interro
intéropérabilité vous pouvez avoir
facebook et new book si mon ami et sur
new book peu importe je paie toujours
communiquer avec cette personne mais
imaginez que nous sommes tous sur
facebook imaginez que nous sommes des
clones facebook facebook si chacun sur
un serveur différent mais que moi je
veux montrer une photo de mon bébé au
lieu d'envoyer un e-mail qui va un seul
serveur
ce qu'engendre un email une fois qu'il a
envoyée il envoyait je ne peux pas le
récupérer le parti de l'inter
opérabilité si on à l'interopérabilité
des réseaux session alors cette photo va
être envoyée à tous les réseaux sociaux
peut-être ans en russie
peut-être ailleurs je ne sais pas si ça
va me convenir imaginez que deux ans se
passe et que je décide que finalement je
ne veux pas que mes enfants ne soient
sur internet alors j'enlève la photo de
new beaucoup de facebook à ce moment là
un message b30 envoyé à tous les petits
clones facebook en demandant merci
d'effacer les photos de son bébé mais
s'ils ne le font pas je pense que à ce
moment là pour garantir la sécurité des
individus il va falloir être très
envahissant parce que souvenez vous il y
a quand même d un dvd moment où il va
falloir éliminer des informations
personnelles dans le cas de harcèlement
par exemple ou de violence domestique et
c'est très difficile à faire appliquer
je ne pense pas que ce soit simple du
tout alors pour en revenir à facebook on
est un peu englués
il y avait quelques pays dans le monde
qui avait d alternative à facebook et cp
ils n'ont plus d'alternative à facebook
il ya trois ans il y avait encore des
alternatives existent et or aujourd'hui
facebook est dominant pour tous ceux qui
réseaux sociaux personnels dans tous les
pays du monde c'est comme
une entreprise de service public lorsque
vous en lorsque vous utilisez le
téléphone vainement des pas qui est
l'entreprise vaut téléphoner c'est tout
donc il va falloir
dérégulation et ce qui est difficile
dans domaine technologique c'est que les
choses vont très vite aujourd'hui nous
avons des problèmes qui sont sans cesse
changeants si on construit des barrières
fais on va trouver un moyen de
contourner ces barrières ce que j'aime
dans le dessin c'est qu'il a un modèle
de la d'évaluation des risques il
demande aux entreprises d'évaluer ses
propres risques
et pour revenir à mon plan trois phases
en fait facebook ne peut pas être le
seul arbitre
et des auditeurs qu'ils sont
recruté par facebook ne peuvent pas
faire un travail tout à fait objectif il
va falloir qu'un tiers puisse le faire
parce que facebook n'est pas assez
diversifiée pour comprendre les
problèmes qu'ils créent dans le monde il
ya quelques changements qui à mon avis
de voix veut se produire dans le décès
alors le premier changement c'est les
tables dehors la communauté doit avoir
son mot à dire
et deuxièmement il faut s'assurer que
ces audits ne couvre pas seulement des
contenus légaux mais également des
contenus
légaux et nuisible donc c'est important
dans le cadre de ce modèle d'avoir une
évaluation des risques par les
entreprises et puis savoir quelles
données seront utilisées pour cette
évaluation est temps que nous avons un
moyen de faire en sorte que ces
entreprises doivent rendre des comptes
et montré qu'elles font des efforts et
des progrès on avancera et il faut il ne
faut pas oublier donc tous les contenus
tels que
je les la santé mentale qui peuvent
nuire à la santé mentale des enfants par
exemple
ces contenus ne sont pas forcément
illégaux sont des contenus légaux mais
qui sont également toxique ensuite il y
a également le secret et des affaires
ça fait des semaines maintenant que je
témoigne et que je parle de choses que
facebook considère comme à la dictée
secrets
commerciaux et à ce moment là les
données sur les algorithmes ne sont pas
publiés donc je pense que cette
disposition sur le sucre est le
commercial devrait être
éliminé enfin lorsque vos
en matière de données très souvent ces
données vont à des universités à un
tiers de tous les tweets par exemple
vont à tout le monde il est environ dix
mille euros chercheurs indépendants
qui observe la situation et une grande
partie des opérations
influençable sur facebook
sont observés
mais il faut davantage de données qui
soient disponibles
pour que les universitaires y aient
accès alors tout le monde n'a pas fait
des thèses mais il faut que l'accès de
ces données soit ouverte à tous que nous
puissions plus facilement trouver la
nocivité des contenus une question
également sur les révélations interne
donc les gars thouars pour revenir la
santé mentale des adolescents on a vu
que depuis 2010 8 facebook est au
courant des dommages faits à la santé
mentale des adolescents mais en fait ils
ont dit que la recherche étaient
mixtes
je pense qu étant donné l'influencé de
facebook et les sommes colossales dont
ils disposent 6 en un an ou 18 mois le
le problème n'est pas
résoudre c'est simplement parce qu'il
souhaite ne pas payer pour les autres je
pense que tous ces discussions autour de
ce sujet ils doivent être abordées de
façon interne si les questions ne sont
pas posées et je pense que très souvent
le choix qui est fait et d'arrêter les
recherches internes imprimés révélation
par exemple ce sont les choix qui vont
peut-être être fait et ce moment là il
n'y aura plus de recherches sur ce qui
se passe à nos enfants parce qu'ils ont
trop peur des résultats des recherches
enfin concernant les lanceurs d'alert je
pense que votre avant projet de loi est
extraordinaire j'aime le fait qu'on
protège donc les
lanceurs d'alert les entreprises
également publics et privés par exemple
c'est moi je travaillais pour le tictoc
je n'aurais pas pu bénéficier de la même
protection
de lanceurs d alerte je pense qu'il faut
encourager la protection des
collaborateurs actuels et des anciens
collaborateurs des sociétés également
parce que beaucoup lui enserre dallas
sont d'anciens employés
et
je pense également qu'il
est important de noter que les lanceurs
d'alerté ne peuvent pas toujours tout
s'exprimer parce qu'ils n'ont pas
toujours de l'argent moi je suis
relativement plus âgés que les autres
nous lançons d'alert et l'argent est un
problème il n'est pas toujours facile
de s'exprimer il n'ya pas toujours les
soutien adéquat et je pense que
travailler sur ces modèles est important
et beaucoup de lanceurs d'alert qui très
souvent
ressentent des syndromes proche du
syndrome post traumatique
en fait c'est comme si vous déteniez un
secret vous avez un secret qu'il vous
emmène à craindre pour la sécurité des
autres il arrive un moment où vous
rendez compte que vous ne pouvez pas
résoudre ce problème seul en interne ce
qui est mon cas
très souvent lorsque les gens en interne
sonné la sonnette d'alarmé et et
simplement viré
il n'avait plus accès à rien du tout du
jour au lendemain et personne ne savait
ce qui se passait et puis une fois qu'on
leur donne accès
on se rend compte que toutes les données
tout ce que cette personne écrit tout a
été effacé
on facebook c'est
que des gens qui sont donneurs
d'alarmant third alertes sont des
menaces et moi un moment donné je me
suis dit qu'il fallait que j'arrête
de n'être que la roue grands centres du
carrosse parce que ça ne mener nulle
part parce que chez facebook tout ce que
vous risquez c'est d'être
d'être licencié
donc il fallait aller plus loin pour ce
qui est des états unis on s'est dit fier
en europe mais aux états unis il n'y a
pas un système de santé tels que en
europe et moi j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup
de chance d'avoir vécu avec ma mère
l'année dernière à cause de la colline
je pensais qu'on ne me prendrait pas au
sérieux mais ma mère vous savez toulouse
est un prêtre et j'ai réussi à
bénéficier de thérapies
pendant des heures et des heures parce
que je vais vu avec un prêtre et les
gens me demander mais comment vous
arrivez à être aussi calme aussi sereine
gdb - j'ai réussi à bénéficier d'un
d'une thérapie de six mois l'année
dernière et beaucoup n'ont pas ce même
niveau de soutien et avoir quelqu'un qui
puisse accompagner psychologiquement les
gens sont c'est très important
sans cela les dommages causés aux
personnes sont énormes voilà pour cette
première série de questions je remercie
madame la présidente
merci beaucoup monsieur le président sur
la question de la rémunération
vous n'avez pas tout à fait répondu
madame hogan j'aimerais bien que vous
nous préciser si vous
[Rires]
donc oui je disais que vous aviez en
partie répondu sur l'aspect financier
expliquant que vous aviez une assise
financière qui faisaient que vous aviez
pu lancer cette alerte sans être
inquiété sur le plan personnel de
manière financière mais est-ce que vous
avez été rémunéré pour cette cette
alerte c'est important parce que c'est
une différence majeure qui existent en
autres dans nos deux régimes et comme
nous nous apprêtons à légiférer sur ce
sujet j'aimerais vraiment avoir votre
regard sur cette rémunération du lanceur
d'alert je vais redonner la part
maintenant nos collègues pour des
questions encore plus ramassées que tout
à l'heure si nous voulons que tout le
monde puisse prendre la parole donc en
premier madame laetitia a bien
merci mais non merci madame la
présidente je suis président d'un organe
aussi je salue bien entendu votre
courage et je vous remercie d'avoir mis
la lumière sur les contradictions entre
les grandes déclarations de facebook et
la réalité de leur action plutôt de leur
inaction ces sujets dont nous nous
sommes très tôt saisi ici à l'assemblée
nationale avec une régulation des
contenus sur les sujets de la
désinformation et de la haine en ligne
et votre intervention ici elle est
particulièrement intéressante pour
identifier objective et quantifier les
choses vous ne parlez pas que de
passivité mets de choix délibéré est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire sur la base de
quels documents quel comité corse ont
pris ces décisions est ce qu'il existe
aujourd'hui des éléments qui permettent
d'identifier le profit qui est générée
par des contenus violents dangereux
illégaux et en ce cas est ce qu'il faut
ou pas on faire la transparence
notamment dans les rapports de
transparence du digitaux de service et
êtes
vous avez évoqué aussi votre travail sur
les systèmes de recommandations et
l'ebit algorithmique qui sont un vrai
danger pour le pluralisme notamment en
matière démocratique
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
corriger ses algorithmes quitte à
renforcer le rôle éditoriale de ces
plateformes ou plutôt aller sur des
systèmes par exemple d'opt out qui
permettrait à chacun de choisir ou non
d'entrer dans une bulle algorithmique
toujours merci
je vous remercie monsieur dino cinieri
même si on a mis la présidente oui
malgré l'interdiction de principe d'être
inscrits sur les réseaux sociaux avant
l'âge de 13 ans plus de la moitié des
enfants entre 8 et 11 ans disent avoir
quant aux personnels sur au moins un
réseau social tik tok 54% soit 51%
youtube quand il pose en jouant l'hymne
32% instagram 25% dans nos permanences
avec madame sylvie bonnet des parents
sont très inquiet car leurs enfants ont
également indiqué utiliser des réseaux
sans y être personnellement inscrits
soit en utilisant le canda membres de la
famille soit celui d'un ami par ailleurs
un enfant sur six dit s'être déjà sentis
en danger sur les réseaux sociaux les
enfants ne comprennent pas encore la
notion de limites sociales ils peuvent
publier des informations personnelles
sur internet par exemple sur leurs
profits sur les réseaux sociaux qui ne
devrait pas être visible de tous il peut
s'agir d'imagés représentant des moments
personnels embarrassant ou la tour
l'adresse de leur domicile par rapport à
ce que vous avez vu de l'intérieur
pensez vous que facebook est sincère
dans sa démarche quand il dit pourquoi
protéger des jeux des risques sur
internet que ce soit par rapport à la
pédocriminalité le super seulement où
l'addition de haut et qu'en fait tout un
lien entre la hausse de suicide chez les
adolescents et les réseaux sociaux
je vous remercie pour le groupe modem
ceci 20 réservés
je remercie madame la présidente merci
madame à horgen j'aurai deux questions
spécifiques rapide vous n'avez pas été
très explicite sur les représailles que
vous avez pu subir ou pas est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un mot et sur
les l'un des aspects qu'on essaye de
résoudre dans la proposition de loi
qu'on va arriver concerne les coûts de
la défense qui peuvent être supportés
par l' attaque est-ce que comment
faites-vous pour financer vos avocats
est ce que c'est sur vos fonds propres
est ce qu'il ya des dispositifs qui
existent pour y aider et enfin le
dernier point qui était la question la
présidente on s'apprête nous en tout cas
dans la proposition d'exclure les
contributions enfin les les
contreparties financières directes à une
alerte pour éviter ce que nous on
appelle parfois un peu chasseur de
primes pour éviter ce phénomène là qu'en
pensez-vous le modèle américain exclut
pas ça quelle est votre position sur ce
sujet merci beaucoup les merci d'être là
et je vous rassure le texte qu'on
s'apprête à débattre contre concerne les
salariés et les anciens salariés ces
terres de vaud une de vos interrogations
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue madame
christine et nyon
merci madame merci madame la présidente
remercie madame pour votre courage votre
ténacité et votre éclairage ans nous
avons beaucoup parlé déjà du ds à mais
le
le panel de textes européens c'est aussi
le dma donc la régulation des marchés
est également un texte sur la régulation
de l'intelligence artificielle ans par
son principe et sa construction ce
règlement soit l'intelligence
artificielle emprunte beaucoup aux rg [ __ ]
qui est un texte fondateur sur la
protection des données personnelles qui
a démontré le leadership européen dans
le domaine mais qui malheureusement n'a
pas permis de rétablir un équilibre
économique en faveur des entreprises
européennes et qui montre aussi ses
limites comme on en a parlé notamment
sur les enfants donc dans mon mandat
parlementaire j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler sur ces sujets et
dernièrement nous avons voté donc une
proposition de résolution européenne qui
se rapporte aux dma est l'une des
recommandations à l'issue de ces travaux
est d'améliorer la transparence des
algorithmes et d'en rendre la
communication possibles et plus
systématiques
donc j'aimerais savoir ce que vous en
pensez
à noter donc que nous avons aussi voté
dans la loi bioéthique une obligation
donc d'expliquer habilités des
algorithmes hersant domaine de la santé
je vous remercie madame cécile un terme
à ja
oui merci merci madame la présidente
merci madame de votre témoignage
moi j'ai je suis très embarrassé et
assez impressionné effectivement par
votre témoignage c'est le meilleur et le
pire on est dans une situation
dramatique et on a le sentiment en fait
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de moyens pour
résister à cette a7 à cet événement
médiatique et mondialisée je voulais
vous poser une question sur la
responsabilité
de l'information d'information poster
sans
sans avoir une idée particulière à ce
sujet je rêve mais vous entendre sur la
question de l'anonymat de l'information
dans le dispositif facebook au travers
des usagers aussi et des responsables de
l'entreprise elle-même est ma deuxième
question c'est sur la transparence des
algorithmes mais si vous vous avez une
explication sur la réticence que nous
avons de la part de nos gouvernements à
aller dans le sens de la transparence
des algorithmes sur des outils qui sont
mis à disposition des administrés je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur cédric villani
micro s'il vous plaît merci madame la
présidente madame à horgen je salue
votre courage et votre parole
contribution cruciale à un débat de
notre temps pour ma part je me souviens
de ma stupéfaction en entendant en 2017
à la traditionnellement très technophile
conférence ted la quantité
d'avertissement contre l'action des
réseaux sociaux comme a pu le dire scott
galloway ce qui met réellement le feu
aux poudres l'équivalent du tabac pour
notre génération sont les réseaux
sociaux et les algorithmes qui ont
déterminé que la colère était le chemin
le plus sûr menant à plus d'engagement
de clics et de publicité ces dernières
années en france des auteurs comme serge
tisseron laurence d'hautvillers gérald
bronner ou encore la version française
du documentaire de sochaux-le dilma nous
ont largement vulgariser ces dérives
d'une part vous confirmer ses analyses
mais l'autre par votre voix experte
vient aussi nous dire que certaines
entreprises sont pires que d'autres
qu'il nous faut auditer et contrôlée
pouvez vous nous en dire plus sur
d'abord les bonnes pratiques
algorithmique et comment les contrôler
sans forcément avoir besoin d'entrer
dans les entrailles de l'algorithme
mystérieux souvent même pour les experts
qui l'ont imaginé et deuxièmement quel
bon modèle économique pour aller avec je
vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur jean-michel
miss
merci madame la présidente phosphore
déchets organiques
chantier de questions brèves pouvez vous
nous donner des têtes des détails sur le
programme e et xi check
qui accorde un statut spécifique à
certains utilisateurs qui ne sont pas
oubliés soumis aux règles
traditionnelles de modération des
publications et son corollaire le
programme le concept les pratiques
système qui permet à des états également
d'avoir un accès privilégié à la
modération et aux contenus
préjudiciables entre guillemets selon
des états et leur maturité démocratique
et deuxième question vous fait un
parallèle assez fréquemment sur
l'industrie du tabac est ce que vous
pouvez à votre connaissance nous
indiquer si l'écriture des algorithmes
de facebook prévoit ou recommande au
delà du fait de deux là elle une vraie
addiction est ce que dans l'écriture
même des algorithmes cela est traduit de
manière systémique merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup malgré de près aux divers
merci
vous vous rendez compte qu'à une vraie
mobilisation en france et puis en europe
autour de ce sujet pour éviter les
dérives de facebook mais il faut
maintenir quand même un difficile
équilibre entre la liberté d'expression
et la protection des usagers face aux
contenus illicites c'est ce à quoi on
s'attache je vais savoir si vous pensiez
que les règles applicables à la presse
écrite qui jouit d'une grande liberté et
dont les contenus diffamatoires ou
injurieux sont passibles de sanctions
sans pour autant être censuré pourrait
être un modèle de régulation pour
l'espace numérique
bref
merci beaucoup stéphane travert pour
terminer cette série de questions
merci madame la présidente madame haugen
merci de votre présence eux devant la
représentation nationale nous menons
actuellement ici une mission relative à
l'abstention et la participation
électorale et on le voit bien
aujourd'hui l'affluence des réseaux
sociaux qui deviennent bien souvent des
réseaux à sociaux modifient le débat est
bien souvent les termes du débat que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur ces nouvelles
influences dans le débat électoral leur
impact sur le fonctionnement de nos
démocraties modernes entre l'information
est fausse information quelle solution à
votre avis pourrait être mise en place
pour décliner la responsabilité à la
fois des auteurs des contenus qui sont
mis en ligne et la responsabilité des
hébergeurs merci
merci beaucoup madame haugen je vous re
cède la parole pour répondre à ces
questions et est la première que j'avais
posé sur la rémunération j'insiste
très souvent j'ai entendu de façon
implicite ou explicite parler de cette
frustration que nous sommes impuissants
qu'il n'y a rien que nous puissions
faire pour que la situation change or si
je veux que vous sentiez cette salle
aujourd'hui avec une chose c'est avec de
l'espoir et pas du désespoir parce que
facebook est au courant de beaucoup de
choses qu'ils pourraient faire et
les problèmes ce n'est pas qu'il y ait
de mauvaises individus ou de mauvaise
idée le problème c'est le système le
système qui de façon systématique choisi
les idées les plus extrêmes pour
atteindre le plus grand nombre de
personnes c'est ça le problème et
facebook est conscient de beaucoup de
choses qu'il pourrait faire pour que ce
système soit plus sûr pour que ces
préjugés implicite au sein de
l'intelligence artificielle
n'existe plus on l'a dit tout à l'heure
la colère c'est ce qu'ils ont engrangés
plus grand nombre de clics donc on
connaît les solutions mais toutes ces
solutions
enlève fait ici et là en côte profit de
facebook et or facebook n'est pas
d'accord avec cela ne veut pas sacrifier
ses profits pour la lutte contre cette
haine
et contre les divisions donc en gros
nous savons comment faire changer les
choses facebook délibérément choisi de
ne pas le faire enfin on m'a posé une
question sur la rémunération est ce que
j'ai été rémunérée je n'ai pas été
rémunéré du tout
j'ai
d'ailleurs ans et de négatif de 25 dans
cars 2 2 millions de dhs alors
aujourd'hui mes services ont été
données
c'est mais c'est grâce aux donations que
j'ai pu que j'ai pu agir c'est grâce à
tous les donateurs j'ai reçu du soutien
mais je n'ai pas été rémunéré du tout je
crois que tout le monde que quelqu'un a
demandé tout à l'heure saks
a posé une question sur les révélations
des contenus qu'ils ont été enlevés je
pense que ce qu'il faut faire déjà s'est
embrassé la diversité linguistique car
j'ai répété à maintes reprises que
facebook a beaucoup investi dans les
contenus en en anglais avec plus de 80%
et
les contrôles il des contenus en anglais
or il ya beaucoup de langues qu'on ne
comprend pas et
qui sont dans des endroits très fragile
facebook parle des programmes
avec de nombreux partenaires mais
lorsqu'ils disent nous soutenons 50
langues ils ne disent pas que les
langues les plus rares
nock ten pratiquement pas de deux font
même le l'anglais britannique qui est
plus vulnérable que l'anglais américain
vous savez je sais les gens sortent du
visuel n'est pas intelligente parce
qu'elle ne saisit pas toutes ses nuances
donc je pense qu'une
façon de forcer
facebook à soutenir un ensemble
diversifié de delon c'est qu'ils doivent
dire quel contenu a été éliminé au
quelle langue et pourquoi quelles sont
les raisons dans lequel se contenant a
été éliminée et on se rendrait compte
que le français par exemple bénéficient
pas de tous les systèmes de sécurité
dont bénéficie l anglais est que partout
en europe il y a les parents pauvres de
ce système or il nous faut plus de
transparence sur ce système quels sont
les langues
et quelle est l'efficacité de ces
systèmes par langue parce que d'après
les données que j'ai vu beaucoup de
langues y compris le français on tue des
problèmes de sécurité important par
exemple la désinformation sur la coved
et c'est quelque chose de vraiment
important nous vivons dans un monde qui
est extrêmement diversifié d'un point de
vue linguistique et les zones les plus
fragiles dans le monde
ont souvent une grande diversité
linguistique ne sont pas prises en
compte les urnes ces questions également
concernant les changements algorithmique
et comment nous pouvons comprendre les
algorithmes faire en sorte qu'ils soient
en ligne avec la démocratie et qu'il ne
se soit pas clivant pour nos populaire
siona mark zuckerberg lui-même a dit en
2018 il a écrit cinq mille mots dessus
et l'a dit que le classement ils fondés
sur les engagements
et nocifs et nous le savons tous les
demis pas grave à ce moment là on
trouvera le contenu ils ont l'éliminera
mais la domination de facebook a montré
que pour ce qui est des discours haineux
3 4 % seulement
sont enlevées 10 à 20 % parfois des
discours haineux mais c'est un problème
parce que on sait qu'il ya des systèmes
dangereux mais l'intelligence
artificielle ne peut pas nous aider
contre c'est un leurre et je pense que
les réseaux sociaux peuvent revenir à
l'échelle humaine
revenons à 2008 2009 on appelle fil
d'actualité on avait le contenu de nos
amis dessus les gars quelle était la
différence entre cette version du fils
d'actualités est la nôtre aujourd'hui
bien facebook récemment après des
expériences et a dit si vous voyez
davantage de contenu de vos familles ou
de vos amis qu'autre chose vous aurez
forcément moins de polarisation
-2 d'image pornographique mondiale ans
en général alors pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que lorsqu'on voit des contenus
de la part de notre famille de nos amis
on est plus en sécurité et bien c'est
parce que ce qui provoque les problèmes
de désinformation ce qui provoque les
problèmes de complots qui auraient du
complot on ne vient pas de nos familles
et où deux des conversations qu'on a
avec nos amis c'est une hyper
amplification des choix de produits et
des groupes géants par exemple on a
parlé d'une page avec 1,8 million de
followers c'est un exemple patent
prochain il ya les groupes en fait
facebook a encouragé les gens à
rejoindre des groupes depuis des années
et ces groupes sont sélectionnés en
fonctionne un classement basé sur
l'engagement et par conséquence de
l'année dernière j'ai eu un scandale 65%
des personnes en allemagne ont rejoint
des groupes nazis en allemagne parce que
facebook a recommandé ces groupes à ces
personnes c'est incroyable
pourquoi et bien parce que facebook
souhaite que vous restiez plus longtemps
sur une plate forme c nous avions un
facebook est plus concentré sur la
famille et les amis alors vous ne
sauriez pas autant en ligne vous
utilisez riez - facebook et facebook
c'est qu'en matière d'addiction de
dépression
les personnes qui sont déprimés
sont à risque
si vous êtes par exemple récemment
divorcée si vous avez récemment déménagé
ou si vous avez perdu votre conjoint
votre conjointe vous êtes plus
vulnérables pourquoi et bien parce que
ces personnes car s'auto apaisé vont en
ligne et cherche des contenus et la
seule passion dont facebook peut vous
aider à regarder un maximum de contenu
par jour pour cécile où vous vous font
rejoindre ces gros groupe parce qu'un
groupe d'un million de personnes a
énormément de contenu mais le problème
ici c'est que lorsque facebook cherche
vos priorités dans vos fils d'activité
et que vous êtes encouragés à rejoindre
un groupe est bien ce groupe va produire
1000 pièces ou 5000 pièces de contenu
par jour facebook temps choisir deux ou
trois ou cinq pour mettre dans le fil
d'actualité ils peuvent pas remettre
5000 et comme nous en avons parlé déjà
tout à l'heure
c'est la colère qui
engendre le plus de réactions est donc
plus un commentaire est négatif plus le
fil d'actualités négative plus vous
allez avoir de clics est donc ce langage
de l'argent regardons et les argos
algorithmes suivent donc la division la
colère ainsi nous arriver à une
situation où chaque personne
qui fait partie du groupe
peut participer à cette viralité c'est
le problème avec facebook
la raison pour laquelle je recommande ce
plan en trois faces pour les audits
c'est qu'aujourd'hui facebook peut dire
mais nous sommes tous conscients du
problème une petit travaillons mais on
n'obtient jamais de données sur des
problèmes spécifiques qui nous
permettrait de suivre leurs progrès par
exemple la désinformation
scandale
lorsque j'ai rejoint l'entreprise
concernant une alerte enseignant
pendant
neuf mois
facebook a travaillé pour limiter la
désinformation on s'est rendu compte que
l'effet inverse est arrivé pourquoi bien
parce que beaucoup beaucoup de
changements on rajouter à la
désinformation
comme porte que l'équipe de sécurité
travaillent d'arrache-pied
cela n'a pas résolu le problème qui
s'est justement aggravée or si nous
avions tous les six mois des systèmes de
contrôle si nous avions des données j'ai
parlé avec des règlements avec des
régulateurs et ils m'ont dit que
facebook était trop cher pour récupérer
des dos des données deux fois par an
mais si on si on demande des données une
fois on peut demander des systèmes tout
simplement toutes les semaines les
systèmes peuvent le faire très
facilement donc ne laissait pas faiblir
ne le sait pas nous ne sait pas dire que
c'est trop difficile de fournir les
données deux fois par an
donc lorsque vous essayer d'évaluer les
progrès il faut demander des derniers
façon hebdomadaire est comme ça on peut
suivre la progression et nous voulons
dit milieu nous voulons des personnes
comme moi qui ne vont peut-être pas
travailler pour le gouvernement pour les
universités mais qui me veulent avoir
les données qu'ils veulent voir les
données pour pouvoir
agiter le drapeau rouge si besoin on ne
veut pas que ce soit une entreprise
privée qui s'occupe de cela uniquement
et je pense que nous avons beaucoup
d'opportunités ici pour faire des
changements de produits par exemple et
ils
nous disent vous n'allez pas aimer les
classement chronologique mais il ya des
façons
de résoudre ces problèmes
et de deux dernières choses ensuite je
vous redonne la parole
premièrement concernant les adolescents
ces images permanentes sont un énorme
problème en effet la recherche interne
de facebook
montre que très souvent les frères et
soeurs plus âgés doivent expliquer à
leurs frères et soeurs plus jeunes
comment utiliser les réseaux sociaux or
ces ados en fait d'ici mi 2010
par exemple vous ne pouvez tu peux pas
être vraiment toi même sur facebook
il faut faire attention et et facebook a
peur de l'autocensure et parce qu'ils
veulent et dieu contenu et les enfants
ne savent pas
quel type de poste les empêchera d'avoir
accès à l'université ou accès à un
emploi je pense que le droit à l'oubli
ou avoir des plateformes qui
vraiment permettent aux enfants à l'âge
de 18 ans de complètement effacé leur
leur passé et c'est important et il est
également présent il est surtout très
important de parler aux enfants et de
les éduquer à cela enfin je pense que
facebook devrait publier pas seulement
des chiffres
sur ce que nous disent les les enfants
il ya ce qu'on appelle les âges estimez
vous savez facebook à des données
aujourd'hui qui montre que pour
certaines tranches d'âge 10 à 15% des
des enfants de 10 ans par exemple sont
sur facebook 10 à 15 % des enfants de 10
ans je suis sur près c'est la même chose
pour instagram et on se dit mais comment
vous obtenez ces chiffres et bien il y à
beaucoup d'enfants qui ne mentent pas et
il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui elles ne
vont pas sur les plates formes avant
l'âge mais
il y en a d'autres qui le font et vous
pouvez connaître les âges laisser
personne en regardant acquis avec elle
communique etc
et donc on pourrait voir sur les enfants
de 13 14 ans combien d'entre eux étaient
déjà sur les plates formes à 10 à 10 ans
et on se rendrait compte de l'envergure
du programme du problème et aujourd'hui
on doit simplement les croire
et on pourrait dire à facebook à cet
intéressant vous faites abc milliards d
e f également on ne sait pas aujourd'hui
ce que fait facebook ou juste donc on ne
peut pas poser les bonnes questions il
ya une question également pour mme
autour de l'addiction chez les
adolescents facebook
engendre de de l'addiction
et l'utilisation problématique de
facebook
se trouvent surtout aux alentours de 13
14 ans il ya des enfants qui sont
suffisamment conscients pour
voir que leur utilisation est nocive et
a des répercussions négatives sur leurs
résultats scolaires par exemple on
facebook
c'est que
25% des enfants ont des problèmes
d'addiction
et pour revenir à la cigarette on est
seulement 10% des ddd fumeurs ont un
cancer là on est un taux beaucoup plus
important de nuisance chez les
adolescents
sortie et les enfants lorsqu'ils sont
déprimés sorte sur les réseaux sociaux
pour trouver des solutions sur
l'anorexie l'anorexie par exemple or les
algorithmes qui pousse vers des
situations extrêmes si vous recherchez
des informations sur comment vous
alimentez scellement vous allez pousser
vers des contenus sur l'anorexie
et enfin
il faut absolument vérifier les
identités des personnes très souvent les
gens dans le monde n'ont pas de système
d'identité est informatique et ce qui va
se passer c'est que les personnes ont
utilisé
des faux d'identité vont
faire semblant d'être au ghana ou
ailleurs où il n'ya pas de supervision
et utiliseront les produits
que
ce sera très difficile de vérifier les
les identités je remercie coup je vous
demander de couper votre micro alors je
vais annoncer les inscrits en essayant
de tenir une minute si un ou deux
supplémentaires ne sont pas ce qu'elles
vous inscrivez auprès thierry je me suis
au lit et monsieur la tombe à ce goût
fish à monsieur et madame ménard
monsieur matra sera même peut-être sur
etb roth et monsieur mahjoubi c'est bon
on y va sacha oublié merci monsieur le
président merci madame haugen pour une
disponibilité pour aux éclairages moi
j'ai deux questions vous avez d'abord
évoqué la transparence des données comme
un élément essentiel et transparentes ce
les contenus retirer ou les motifs la
transparence sur les algorithmes de
classement d'auckland à sion en revanche
vous êtes opposés à la suppression des
algorithmes de classement et donc
j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous dire
en quoi il est préférable de conserver
un algorithme alternative plutôt que de
les supprimer purement et simplement à
ce sujet la deuxième question c'est sur
les reproches qui peuvent vous être fait
par certains critiques les plus radicaux
sur la concentration des pouvoirs votre
ancien employeur revendique le fait
d'avoir un système de contrôle là où
d'autres opérateurs stocks ou ou twitter
pour pas les citer n'en auraient pas
est-ce que
on ne pourrait pas imaginer sur cette
concentration des pouvoirs la casser ou
en tout cas là me nuire notamment avec
des systèmes de contrôle décentralisés
ou en tout cas des systèmes de contrôle
par les citoyens de l'information et des
algorithmes c'est des dispositions qui
pourraient être mis en place avec des
logiciels en pratique avec des outils
comme la blocs chaînes comme nous
connaît que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
merci effet les plateaux merci monsieur
le président mes questions vont porter
sur la suite de votre alerte g seront
précisés courte la première pensez vous
que le changement non et la volonté
d'accélérer dans le métavers c'est une
stratégie volontaire de noyer le poisson
des agissements passés pour essayer de
retrouver une sorte de virginité
réputationnel à la suite de vos
révélations et si oui est-ce que ça peut
marcher selon vous deuxième question
gonchar un peu du cadre mais c'est
toujours lié à facebook que pensez vous
de la stratégie de facebook d'investir
dans les autoroutes de l'internet et
notamment dans les câbles sous marins
est ce que nous devons y voir menaces
futures que nous devrions traiter
préventivement je vous remercie
merci c'est l'impression qu'elle a plus
celle là guillaume gauthier chat
richard lioger merci monsieur le
président nous sommes madame hagan très
honoré par votre présence car le courage
dont vous avez fait preuve est un
exemple pour nous tous très souvent les
débats sur les réseaux sociaux sont
centrés sur ce que l'on appelle l'effet
news et le poids que peuvent avoir les
interférences étrangères sur notamment
sur les scrutins ce fut notamment le cas
aux états-unis en 2016 lors de
l'élection de donald trump mais nous
sommes nombreux à penser que cela
pourrait aussi se produire en france et
ça peut être produit en france à
l'occasion des prochaines élections
présidentielles la question sera simple
c'est une seule question comment agir
pour que l'avenir de nos démocraties ne
dépendent pas d'entité monopolistique
comme facebook souvent confrontés aux
limites de ces modérateur merci merci
emmanuel bédard
allez-y pardon rappuyer
maxi monsieur le président madame agon
merci à vous également une question très
courte vous avez parlé d'une nécessaire
contrôle des contenus nuisibles mais
néanmoins légaux je voulais vous poser
la question suivante qui décide qu'un
contenu est nuisible alors qu'il est
légal et que préconisez vous exactement
comme contrôle de ces contenus je vous
remercie merci fabien matras
merci monsieur le président je tiens
comme mes collègues à saluer votre
courage et votre action sur un sujet
aussi important pour toutes les
démocraties à l'heure actuelle facebook
et les autres plateformes représentent à
la fois une chance et une menace pour
nos régimes démocratiques et vos
révélations nous obligent au vu des
risques pesant sur leur image publique
et leurs bénéfices il est légitime de
penser que certains mécanismes de
sécurité sont en train ou ont été mis en
place par cette entreprise afin d'éviter
toute nouvelle fuite d'informations
pourriez vous nous en dire davantage sur
les obstacles qui ont été les vôtres
dans le processus de révélations d
information vous avez exposé et pourrait
vous au-delà de la question financière
nous indiquait qu'elles seraient des
mécanismes pour rendre plus efficace la
protection des lanceurs d'alerté et les
encourage et encourager d'autres
personnes à faire la même démarche que
celle que vous avez effectué ces points
sont importants pour nous puisque nous
sommes adaptés à légiférer sur ces
questions et votre éclairage nous semble
indispensable merci merci annonce total
merci monsieur le président madame le 16
octobre 2020 a eu lui en france un drame
dont vous avez certainement eu
connaissance le 16 octobre 2020 le
professeur d'histoire-géographie samuel
pâtit alors qu'il rentrait chez lui dans
la commune d'hernani a été décapité par
un islamiste
le 5 octobre samuel pâte illustrer un
cours sur la liberté d'expression en
utilisant deux des célèbres caricatures
de mahomet le 7 octobre un parent
d'élève publié un message dénonciateur
sur facebook propageant de fausses
informations sur la nature et le contenu
du cours de samuel pâtit puis plusieurs
vidéos menaçantes sont publiées sur ce
sujet dont une diffusée le 9 octobre sur
la page facebook de la mosquée de pantin
suivie par 95 1000 followers à partir de
ce moment là à la faveur du nombre de
followers c'est l'emballement sur les
réseaux sociaux mensonges et menaces
sont colportées pour accabler et ciblée
samuel pâtit qui finalement portera
plainte le 12 octobre quatre jours avant
sa mort entre le 7 et le 12 octobre le
meurtrier de samuel pas tim abdul haq à
bouillé zee dovic april affaires via les
réseaux sociaux est relayée lui même les
vidéos contre samuel pâtit dont celle du
prédicateur abdel hakim sefrioui qui
entretenait la kabbale numérique
puis il prend contre il prend contact
avec des personnes sur place et le 16
octobre commet l'irréparable un acte de
barbarie qui a bouleversé notre nation
toute entière onze jours séparent le
cours de samuel bâti sur la liberté
d'expression et son assassinat onze
jours durant lesquels les pires infamies
et mensonges se sont déversés de réseaux
sociaux en réseaux sociaux sans
véritable contrôle digne de ce nom alors
ma question est simple à votre avis
madame quel type de drame doit-on
attendre pour que mark zuckerberg et ses
équipes réalisent le danger qu'un manque
de contrôle des réseaux sociaux fait
encourir à la démocratie alors si rémy
rebeyrotte
oui mes chers collègues madame merci
pour votre venue de questions dans vos
rêves
quelles seraient les mesures qu un etat
devrait prendre le plus rapidement
possible pour encadrer justement ces
réseaux sociaux parce qu'on
al'impression fâché nous c'est la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen qui est le socle de nos droits
pour réguler la vie sociale mais que les
réseaux sociaux échappent à cette
régulation même si nous avons progressé
même s'il ya des lois qui ont été posées
nous sommes mois du contre deuxième
élément est ce que vous preniez un
organisme international pour pouvoir
faire face à ces dérives et sortir les
états de leur isolement d'une certaine
manière face aux réseaux sociaux et 3e
et dément je reprends une question qui a
été posée sur l'anonymat sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur les pseudos s quelle est
votre réaction par rapport à cette
question de l'anonymat
merci et pour terminer mouniama j'oublie
merci beaucoup madame haugen merci
encore d'être là ma question elle
portera sur votre expérience à facebook
parce que dans le sujet des lanceurs
d'alert ya le sujet de ceux qui comme
vous partez témoigne médias le sujet de
tous ceux qui restent et qui ne témoigne
pas et donc la question que je vais vous
poser c'est vous quand vous avez
rejoindre cette entreprise déjà pourquoi
est ce que vous l'avez fait qu'est-ce
que vous aviez cru y trouver et pourquoi
ces milliers d'autres collaborateurs
aujourd'hui reste est ce qu'ils sont
complices est-ce qu'ils ont peur ou est
ce qu'ils n'ont tout simplement pas
conscience de ce que vous avez vu et
donc c'est quoi le chemin qui permet
dans une expérience de cadre de
dirigeants de se dire là ça a dépassé
les limites là ça a dépassé nos
frontières je dois partir pour le dire
mais votre collègue vous en ayez
certains vous avez certainement trouver
du talent à beaucoup d'entre eux
pourquoi est-ce que restée quel est le
message que vous pourriez leur passé
merci merci madame la présidente vous
devez poser une dernière question
ensuite madame haugen on vous laissera
conclure et merci encore d'avoir été
parmi nous on a va très bien merci
beaucoup monsieur le président c'est
juste pour avoir une précision par
rapport au modérateur on en a parlé à
plusieurs reprises il ya plusieurs
questions qui ont tourné autour de cela
on sait que facebook a de très nombreux
nos modérateurs mais manifestement ça
n'est pas encore suffisant vous avez
évoqué que certains pays certains usages
dans certaines langues étaient
insuffisamment couverts donc à votre
avis combien faudrait-il de modérateur
dans le monde espèce qui vous imaginez
un ratio par nombre d'utilisateurs par
pays par langue pour que la modération
puisse s'effectuer pleinement merci
beaucoup
la morgan meighen and
you can't take copenhague on tient nos
problèmes
ouais
le
programme avoir demandé comment arriver
à être aussi lorsque vous témoigner j'ai
participé à un débat à l'école et je
n'ai jamais pris autant note
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de contenu alors bon reprenons
pense que facebook doit vraiment publier
le nombre de modérateur par langues
aujourd'hui par exemple tout l'arabe est
traitée comme une langue alors qu'un
arabe il ya beaucoup de familles de
langues différentes et ils sont tout à
fait conscients que du bon travail n'est
pas effectuée dans toutes ces familles
de langues
et donc si des mesures étaient en place
il aurait peut-être moins deux arts
c'est moi je pense qu'il est important
de publier ses ressources
publié les systèmes mis en place par
donc parce que nous vivons dans des
sociétés diversifiées dans un monde
diversifié je peux vous garantir qu'il
n'y a pas suffisamment de modérateur
francophone chez facebook il n'y a pas
assez de systèmes de sécurité en place
en dehors de ceux en ni en anglais et
c'est une problème une
atteinte à la dignité on a une question
également sur le contenu nuisibles et
légale qui
décide il ya un certain nombre de
changements qui doit
s'en sort on travaille davantage échelle
humaine
parce que le système en place ne
fonctionne pas il faut mettre en oeuvre
des choses dans chaque langue alors les
systèmes actuels
amplifie hyper amplifie la situation et
on pense que l'intelligence artificielle
peut sécuriser les choses mais
l'intelligence artificielle ne capte pas
les nuances ne capte pas le contexte est
donc l'intelligence artificielle ne sera
pas amélioré ce problème subsistera il
faut donc arriver à évaluer le contenu
nuisibles et est légal mais il nous faut
des des solutions mais les solutions que
nous avons aujourd'hui ne regarde pas le
contenu non je pense que facebook doit
vraiment se concentrer sur des contenus
nuisibles à la société même si ces
contenus sont légaux ne sont pas
illégaux ici on dit à facebook comment
faire on ne va pas réussir parce que de
toute façon n'a pas accès aux données on
n'a pas accès à l'entreprise mission aux
forces facebook à nous laisser mettre en
place cette approche en trois étapes
c'est comme les étiquettes 1 sur ce
qu'on mange au gouvernement ne vous dit
pas ce qu'il faut manger
mais vous avez des informations sur
l'origine des ingrédients vous avez des
origines sur ce que vous mangez sur la
qualité nutritionnelle de ce que vous
mangez aujourd'hui on n'a pas des deux
équipes qui quêtent pour les réseaux
sociaux les personnes savent pas à quel
point
ils peuvent être nuisibles
pourquoi parce que facebook a caché tous
ses aspects nuisible au public donc dans
cette approche a en trois phases il faut
que facebook
comme unique là dessus et que des
données soient véritablement
indisponibles
parce que pouvoir voir ses données
est essentielle mais aujourd'hui il n'y
a rien qui encourage facebook dans ce
sens
elle ne voit pas des retours des profits
sur le court terme ils n'agiront pas
mais si on les regarde et s'il était
davantage observé il se dirait à il faut
mettre quelque chose en place donc il
faut qu'on change les mesures
incitatives si on veut que facebook
change on a parlé également de legault
rythme alternatif et bien si vous
changez uniquement l'algorithme est pas
d'autres parties du produit vous n'allez
pas amélioré les résultats très
probablement il faudrait protéger
par une loi la capacité à suivre 1 go
par exemple aujourd'hui
c'est arrivé beaucoup avec shannon vous
pouvez inviter chaque individu peut
inviter un grand nombre de personnes à
rejoindre un groupe chaque année
et il y a des gens qui ont évité jusqu'à
300 mille personnes
dans des groupes
complotistes les facebook a injecté donc
le contenu dans le fil d'actualité de
toutes ces personnes je pense qu'il faut
travailler vraiment sur cette pratique
là mais c'est ce que je pense
personnellement il ne pense pas la même
chose
et à chaque fois que ce contenu que les
personnes engagées s'engager notation du
nom de son contenu
ils étaient considérés comme des
followers
il ya une personne qui a permis
de suivre en masse
facebook a lancé à intenter un procès
parce qu'ils veulent pouvoir contrôler
ce qui se passe
mais facebook a montré que si de telles
choses se passaient ils intenteraient
des procès
un jour j'ai lu un article
utilisé qu'à chaque fois que vous
entendez dire que quelqu'un est
courageux
j'ai trouvé imaginer que ces personnes
aient privilégié moi je suis très
privilégié je sais que je peux
communiquer le fait d'avoir peur de
communiquer
fait que beaucoup sont réticents et
reste silencieux
une chose qui arrête beaucoup de
lanceurs dallaire death et qui ne savent
pas quelles sont les prochaines étapes
moi c'était le cas je ne savais pas quoi
faire j'avais peur de demander j'avais
peur de choper recherché
je travaillais sur eux au
contre-espionnage
et
donc j'aurais dû savoir mais en fait les
gens ne savent pas qui contacter
moi j'avais des préoccupations
concernant la sécurité nationale je
pensais qu'il a aidé des agents
extérieurs qui faisait des choses est
que facebook
ne faisait pas assez pour les arts
étaient d'ailleurs en termes de sécurité
nationale j'aurais beaucoup de choses à
dire ses voeux aux etats unis c'est
incroyable si je suis
conductrice de bus j'aurai un numéro de
téléphone que je pourrais appeler
et n'importe qui peut appeler ce numéro
dans le bus si jamais ils sont témoins
de quelque chose qui est dangereux mois
dans le cadre de mon pote je n'ai jamais
eu accès antenne numéro téléphone
alors vous avez également poser des
questions concernant la protection des
facilitateurs et je pense que ça c'est
aussi important que de protéger les
lanceurs d'alerté
enfin je ne pense pas que
rechercher les identités des gens va
aider parce que les gens continueront à
utiliser les vpn pour contourner le
problème savez facebook énormément de
données sur vos dons vous n'êtes pas
anonyme facebook c'est où vous êtes ils
font des choses assez étrange avec les
réseaux de wifi vous seriez assez étonné
de voir tout ce qu'ils peuvent faire il
à une question sur le métavers également
le métavers et question très
préoccupante à mon avis
je pense que leur vision
d'être au sein du de l'environnement de
travail est très préoccupante ils
veulent des capteurs des micros le
système de de surveillance mais imaginez
que vous êtes
chez vous que vous travaillez
de chez vous
et que votre employeur décide d'être une
entreprise de métal verre
bien c'est problématique parce que vous
êtes au sein de votre cadre personnel
hors des micros pourront être le placer
dans ce quart d'un personnel et c'est un
gros problème
enfin il ya une question également sur
un organe international à mettre
éventuellement en place j'ai parlé avec
beaucoup de payer je pense qu'il ya une
véritable opportunité ici même un europe
de l'ouest
si on collabore
et qu'on essaye de négocié avec facebook
en ne faisant qu'un je pense qu'on peut
avoir beaucoup de puissance il eds n'est
pas suffisamment puissant 600
applications si on n'est pas
suffisamment ferme si on se rend compte
que on ne peut pas aller plus loin même
si une poignée de pays se rassemblent je
pense que l'impact pourrait être
extrêmement grand
une loi sur le droit des enfants qui
passaient à cet été on dans l'union
européenne
imaginez une poignée de pays qui s'unit
et collabore je pense que ce serait
quelque chose de très fort et enfin je
suis vraiment heureuse de voir ce qui se
passe en matière de protection des
lanceurs d'alerté il faut continuer ce
travail les technologies
ont de plus en plus vite évolué de plus
en plus rapidement il ya toujours eu un
fossé entre l'évolution des technologies
et les
régulations et soit c'est de rattraper
et de combler ce fossé est dans un monde
où il y à une norme et mende
accélération technologique
c'est problématique
il n'y a qu'une poignée d'experts qui
puisse comprendre ces phénomènes et on a
besoin de personnes comme moi qui
sortent des entreprises qui ne reste pas
seulement au sein de ces entreprises
pour pouvoir dire que le public est en
danger
et je pense que ça c'est très important
d'un point de vue psychologique
également il faut arriver à soutenir ces
gens psychologiquement j'ai parlé à
beaucoup danseurs dallaire qui ont été
complètement écrasées par le phénomène
de lentille de lancer l'alerté je pense
que ce soutien psychologique très
important pour jour merci de votre
attention
merci
merci à tous et à toutes trois petites
remarques rapide d'abord un pour les
membres de la commission des affaires
économique sauf avis contraire de votre
part monsieur alain ramadier désigné
rapporteur pour groupe l'est républicain
pour l'audition de la future directrice
général de l'anru 2 pour nos amis
journalistes il n'y aura pas de
questions de la presse après cette
audition ça a été spécifiquement demandé
par madame hogan et son équipe 3 merci à
la mort g funk you thank you very very
much
thanks for coming from
merci pour votre transparence et pour
votre leadership